Yes,
that's my ode to Brody Stevens.
What's up brother?
How are you?
Good to see Ya mate.
I can't believe I'm here again.
This is awesome.
I'm clam.
Believe you here again too.
I can't believe five days ago you were in a world title fight.
Look at you.
You look great.
Yeah,
it was um,
straight after the fire had their hospital.
I spent about four hours in hospital.
I thought I broke my foot,
but luckily all the x rays came back clear.
Uh,
swelling's going down a lot now.
So I once Asia,
I didn't think I was going to be at a fight December the fifth.
It looks like ammonia with,
I'm sorry.
Oh Wow.
Okay.
So you,
did you kick an elbow or something?
Like he knows I keep these names about half a dozen times.
I didn't hurt and cause my face was so jacked up from all the cuts and then it
wasn't until I was getting stitched up.
Then I noticed my foot was that into go elephant,
try to band and then a,
and then once the stitches,
then I cyborg come into the change room to get a photo of me.
And as I stood up to get a photo with her,
then I realized the pain was rushing to my foot.
I was like,
okay,
I think my foot's broken so straight.
Luckily there was an ambulance there.
We'll get straight into the emergency and then um,
yeah,
it was good onto the,
uh,
the,
the painkillers,
which took me into a different dimension.
What did they give you?
Oh,
it's stuff that's,
um,
different,
different names here in America to Australia,
but I'm like oxy code owns or something like illustrating with an injection.
Probably Morphine.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
this pink elephant came into the room and started chatting to me as in,
hey,
the,
your foot's not broken,
but uh,
you are in a different galaxy now.
Say Welcome.
And that was pretty cool.
It was a really a pink elephant and he just fucking around.
I could be possibly a fucking around.
So you got,
you've had 300 and how many stitches in your 15 year?
Three 15 315 I broke,
I broke 300 about four weeks before I got to America with a,
an accident and the gym,
sparring and I thought okay,
300 year beauty.
And then cosmo was,
cosmo was polite enough to give me another two cuts with another 15 stitches.
So now I thought my,
my plateau was three hundreds and now my next goal is I guess is 400 cause I've
already passed the three point line.
Goodness.
Who's got the most stitches in their face ever.
And my tie.
Oh that's a good question.
I'm not going to have to be close.
I gotta be up there.
I'd have to be,
um,
but I'm starting to now and my doctor,
he said,
uh,
because I bring my own doctor with me when I come to fight everywhere around the
world and he said it's just scars.
Speaking on scars now is um,
the Nick Diaz sorta eyebrows.
So this one's had at least maybe 18 alone.
This,
this ice one laughed.
I 80,
80 still dressed the main cause that's the right elbow two coming down.
So yeah,
well that's the knock on mortar as opposed to glory,
which unfortunately they just got,
they just lost their,
their deal with spike TV or canceled their agreement with spike to you.
I don't know what happens,
but they pulled glory off spike,
which is really very disappointing for me as a fan of a kickboxing.
And I was just hoping that that would translate into,
you know,
just to people getting a more,
more understanding in this country of,
of a
high level kickboxing.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
he um,
glory,
glory was the the one and then the head of the line fight.
So I reached out to Scott Kent with the lion fighting at hell mate.
Is there any chance you can put me on?
Um,
I seen how much exposure that having with access TV and uh,
and with there,
with the deal with everyone in the world is paying attention to the lifeline
right now.
And because it's pure my attire as well,
I thought,
um,
is,
is that this is definitely in the show to try and be on to,
to raise the profile.
So I'm,
I jumped on board and then,
uh,
I'm so devastated that I lost it was,
it was such a tough fight,
but at the same time,
even now I'm lost and I'm sad.
I knew that I,
I gave 100%.
Um,
and hopefully the,
the Crowder was an entertaining enough to hopefully invite me back and hopefully
Scott was happy with my performance.
So was a,
it was a great fun fight.
But what I was going to say is a glory doesn't have elbows.
And the,
the,
the thing that people worry about with like lion fight and pure Moy Tai is that
there's a lot of cuts in,
a lot of people get cut and primarily get cut by elbows.
Yes.
But you know,
the way I look at it,
it's like that is a,
it's a,
it's an excellent weapon.
And if you should be able to kick or if you are able to kick and you're able to
need the face and you're able to do all the things that you can in MMA,
why can't you elbow and in my time,
you know,
and why can't you clinch,
it's exactly the same as MMA.
How can you,
how can you take away the rules and water it down into one sort of category?
And then,
and then called,
I think it's the same deal when they think Corbett came over here,
he's the elbow master.
Um,
and then when he came over here to fight for glory and he got beaten by
spoiling,
he got beaten by Saki and everyone saying,
well,
but if he had his elbows,
that would have changed.
The
maybe,
who knows?
You never know,
but you never know.
Certainly it's,
it makes you think,
and you know when you're thinking that's bad in the cage or the ring or wherever
you're competing,
the idea is to train so hard and train exactly how you're going to fight so that
it all comes out automatically.
And when your automatic instinct for Nathan,
I mean,
how many fights is,
he had a,
I think close to 70.
Yeah.
I mean,
think about all those fights.
Did he add throwing elbows?
Think about all those training sessions,
throwing elbows,
and then all of a sudden he's in positions where it's like,
okay,
don't throw an album because that's normal.
You're getting in the clinch and it just,
it,
it's just normal for you.
Yes.
And then all of a sudden they tell you you can't do it.
I mean,
I,
it's problematic.
I mean it's,
it's nice for these guys to be able to have another outlet.
I know Tyrone,
Tyrone Spong is,
I'm doing some boxing down,
just some straight boxing,
which I think probably at least he has shoes on.
So it'd be just thinking that he's,
you know,
like it'll,
it'll help him not throw kicks and not thinking you can throw elbows and things,
but the guys who are the best and the guys who are the the best,
uh,
at that particular style of Moitai,
it'd be great to see them use all their weapons.
It'd be great to see them utilize all the techniques of Muay Thai.
He see how technical when we tie is,
you know,
I thought,
I don't think people from the outside that are watching it appreciate it for
what it really is.
It's an incredibly intense and technical martial art.
Yeah.
We'll Thailand's uh,
how many hundred years old say it's already a perfected to the,
to the rule set and then everyone's trying to water it down to them to make it
their own specific sorta rule set.
And then,
um,
it's not the authentic,
when you keep it as it is,
it's already,
the products are already there.
You don't have to change it.
It's already,
it's already been fine on perfect enough and fast.
And so it's a,
it's a shame that a different organizations trying to,
but I,
I suppose people don't like the clincher as much.
Sometimes.
I think it's getting a little bit boring.
And plus when you get two guys that aren't,
uh,
at a certain level,
it does seem a little bit sorta doll.
It's not entertaining.
But in the early levels grapplings and very low level.
So it was a lot of things at a low level.
Yes.
But I don't think you should ever sort of make rules that are dictated just to
make people that are at a low level fight in a more fan friendly,
enjoyable way.
I think you should just allow the people that are watching it to see the
difference between a novice and someone who's an expert and see someone who uses
the clinch to their advantage and see all the different techniques that can be
landed from the clinch,
the uses of the need,
the use of the knees,
the elbows from the break.
You know,
there's a lot of beautiful techniques that can be used from the clinch that you
don't see because what glory has done is sort of adopt the rules of k one which
the Japanese had kind of decided,
hey,
there's gotta be a way to make these guys fight in a more exciting and fast
paced way.
What's make the rounds,
you know,
just what's a,
to make the fight shorter instead of having like many rounds,
like 10 rounds or 12 rounds or something like that,
like a boxing match,
let's just do like three rounds and have them go fucking crazy for three rounds,
you know?
Yeah.
When I fought in Europe,
uh,
that was,
that afforded an organization called Super League back in 2003,
2004 and that was the same deal.
Again,
we're not gonna spend airfare,
money flowing all the way from Australia and get cut in the first round and have
the flight stop 60 seconds in.
Otherwise it's a waste of money for us.
So,
so we'll,
we'll,
we'll keep,
the knees will keep everything else,
but we'll just eliminate and elbows just from case to the,
that that does happen.
Does I'm lion fight,
do drug testing?
Uh,
I,
there was no urinary test.
Half the money.
Nothing.
Wow.
And then I think we're in Vegas and uh,
now they've moved to Timmy,
Michaela,
and then I think on the other side as well.
I forget the other place that has,
but um,
no,
there was no,
I'm waiting for a job for me now is a Temecula the,
it's,
it's a casino,
right?
You guys ready?
A Casino Chang goes out.
What it is.
And is that a native American reservation where they can do whatever they want?
They have their own regulations.
Yes.
You know,
they kept a martial arts.
A lot of mixed martial arts live in California.
Okay.
You have a native American reservations did because they put on a king of the
cage in a native American reservations when you couldn't have MMA in California.
It was illegal.
And so we used to drive out to the middle of nowhere to these very small native
American casinos.
And,
uh,
that's where the king of the cage would be.
And that's,
that was like the primary way that,
that's how like Uriah Faber got started.
A lot of guys quit and Jackson got started.
A lot of guys get started and king in the cage and in California because of this
loophole that allows native American reservations put on the fights.
But boy,
I would like it if they drug tested guys.
Yeah.
You know?
I definitely feel a lot safer if I knew it wasn't faithful lighting.
A pure animals did just do the Jews to the tits.
Well,
Cosmo,
Xander is a big fella and um,
he's quite a bit larger than you.
Yeah.
The guy that you fought was,
uh,
he's,
um,
he's a bad six three.
He then went to,
when they announcing this at six one,
but there's no way six one,
when I was looking up at him,
when the referee borders together,
uh,
it was like looking at a Michael Jordan or Sam.
I said,
Holy Shit.
And then,
uh,
and then,
once the fight starts to just,
just trying to present,
get there,
get into his range.
It was either as you explode into,
try and try and learn your combinations,
those knees are flying past,
pass your head left and right.
It's uh,
it's just makes it so much,
so much harder when they say [inaudible] and I'm,
the funny thing is he can make I think seventies,
one 55 he can eat and cut all the way down.
Yeah.
He's,
last fight before he fought me was 79 kilos.
And I know before that he's fought.
It's 70.
And um,
Ben,
he's not a skinny 70.
They once he,
once he feels right out after lane,
he's,
um,
he's still at the muscles and he still looks like if they say he's gay and he's,
and to his credit,
um,
I baiting him back in 2008,
and um,
he's just improved it leaps in Brown's,
um,
the way that he fought me on Friday night.
He fought really well.
He used his range.
He used,
I'm good power.
His power is so in crazy everything.
He's,
everything he hit me with was um,
loaded.
So it good,
full,
full credit to him.
I try my best.
Um,
but yeah,
he was just um,
on his game.
Yeah,
he looked very,
very sharp.
There was some great moments in that fight.
It's really interesting man.
You have a way of moving a very,
a very specific way of moving inside of the octagon or inside the the ring
rather.
If I watched you like it just silhouette of Sherman's,
someone showed me a silhouette of you move and I go,
oh that's John Wayne par.
I got,
you could totally tell it's,
it's so interesting.
You have your own very specific style of a,
of moving.
And I would imagine that that style is like,
I mean,
you do a lot of things that are other more Thai guys do.
Look,
you're very light on the front foot,
but there's a way you have of throwing punches and combinations and so heavy off
that front left leg is very specific to you.
You know,
and I think that for a lot of guys,
let's kind of present them.
Who is your,
um,
it's very effective.
But it's unique,
you know,
and it can,
your style of movement,
it's like,
I don't,
I can't think of another guy.
Like if I watch certain guys,
I go,
oh well that guy fights.
Like this guy.
He kind of moves a little bit like him or Tiago Alva as a sort of like that guy
or you
know,
you could kind of do that with,
with a lot of fighters.
But now with you,
you got it.
This weird sort of unusual timing,
you know,
especially that left leg man.
You're,
you're like one of the best guys have ever seen at that front left leg counter.
Like to the body when a guy's throwing a punch.
And I think you get all that time spending in Thailand that there was one of
their main things.
It was a telling me it's so hard,
the block of the back leg,
um,
cause that lead leg,
so light it,
and then a majority of the time,
90% of the people who are throwing lakes,
so you've got that lead leg ready.
But when next time,
the three that left,
um,
it's really hard the block.
So I've perfected that.
Left on the underpads,
I'm throwing that 70% of the time and my right leg is my power leg,
my left legs might my counter.
So I'm throwing that more than anything.
And then,
uh,
I started off with a really strong right leg and my left leg was okay and I just
worked at at work that it worked at it to make it my main weapon.
And now I'm like a jab for boxer like comes through McKesson weapon.
Yeah.
And then someone,
as soon as someone comes in to strike,
I throw that left leg and it's not only am I trying to school,
but I'm using it as a break to try and stop you from throwing your combinations.
Also,
if I,
if I don't land on your ribs,
I'm hitting your arms.
So I'm pushing you off balance so you can't throw the right hand.
Will I want to try and break that right hand down.
So that's taking the power away from your right punch and you're putting weight
into it too.
And landing with the Shin,
which also keeps the knee and the thigh bone from you to them.
It creates a space.
Yes.
And is a lot of power to it.
If you use that so effectively,
man.
And she should have used it more too because in the after flight speech Cosmo's
saying,
oh,
he was hurting me with that left leg and then um,
to the body.
Right.
He said that on the APP,
the flights and that's like,
ah,
dammit I should have,
I should have used it more.
But there was a couple of unique moments in that fight.
One of them was in the third round when you just opened up with this crazy
flurry.
Yes.
Like what was going on there?
You just have this feeling.
Did you just just say,
I'm just going to put a barrage on this motherfucker and see what happens?
Yeah.
My theory is if I,
if I can get someone covering up,
I'm not going to stop them.
So if the opportunity comes in and if I might take me 30 punches of my time,
if 50 punches,
but eventually I figure if I can find that gap and I hit you hard enough,
I know I can drop you.
So I was just trying my hardest to try and land that big one to try and put him
down.
And I knew that I've done enough work in the gym to to throw all night and my
gas tank was full.
There was no way I was going to guess.
So I just kept throwing,
throwing,
throwing.
I think he'd come on and just lend that good one to just give him,
giving yourself an eight count to get myself back into the game.
But um,
yeah,
he,
I think he wore 30 ish and then,
um,
he got here to the corner and they shrugged it off.
I was like,
dammit,
now I'm screwed.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's funny because you see a guy blocking punches and covering up,
but uh,
guys get knocked out through gloves all the time.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Especially with kicks.
Right.
And then it's,
uh,
I'm also trying to get into your head as well to make you,
try and yeah.
Trying to,
trying to break you down thing in disguise a machine.
How can I stop him?
Um,
yeah,
but unfortunately they didn't work.
He,
because my,
it was,
it was good.
It's very good.
Yeah.
Is another unique moment.
In the fourth round,
you rocked him with a right hand and then he started like cleaning the bottom of
his feet.
Yes.
He was hurt.
He was like,
oh,
that's something on my foot like this.
You just got rock first.
First I thought he lost his mouthpiece and then I,
as,
as I seen him sweat,
I've gone to John Payne and that,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
And then I thought he lost his contact.
I don't know what was going on,
but it was a full like,
no,
you're wrong.
I'm right.
Just a second.
And then,
then it's like,
oh no,
he was fucked.
I should,
I should've jumped on him.
But he played a little mind gay.
I was affecting gay move.
It's like,
stumps up,
stumps up.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
No,
I'm good.
Well there you guys match up at opportunity and you tried to move in and the
referee got away the room.
Very fucked up.
Yay.
He didn't know what was going on either.
He got hustled as well say to each credit he,
he pulled that movie.
Yeah.
That could have been made in my shot where you could tell too,
because after that he wasn't the same.
And then in the fourth round or the fifth round,
rather,
you came on strong in the fifth round.
Fifth round was all you.
I think you heard him bad in that fourth round.
I think you stung him.
That's what their,
that's the only reason why God would ever do like a con move like that.
Like,
hold on man,
I've got to clean the bottom of my feet.
Like,
hey fuck you talking about it.
You don't get to clean the bottom of your feet.
The guys stops
boxing.
It was very strange.
And then,
uh,
we were chatting afterwards and you came into the change room and we had to have
a chat.
Um,
and then you guys,
Oh man,
you wouldn't believe it.
The very last punch you through your broke my nose and I kind of breathe.
So as I've gone into the hospital to the emergency,
he was in one of the other rooms getting these knees put back into together so
you could see his nose leaking when he was talking to pat Miletich his nose was
leaking,
but uh,
he's a tough guy and it seems like a really,
really nice guy too.
We've fought each other three times now.
And then we've also fought on the same cards here in Jamaica,
in Australia and a few other places in,
um,
nicest bloke.
He's just the genuine.
And then even when we've,
we,
we got,
uh,
put together for this fight would message each other privately on Facebook.
And I'm just talking about different things.
So there's no animosity.
It's just,
it's just business,
right?
He's got to get paid.
I've got to get paid.
We,
we beat competition.
Competition.
We beat,
we beat each other up.
And then at the end of it again,
we got on each other's change room.
We high five.
Good fight.
Thank you very much.
Um,
you know,
that's interesting because that's a,
that's a big part of fighting is the comradery between fighters,
but also a big part of fighting is the mental game when there is no camaraderie,
when guys are fucking with each other and it becomes emotional.
And there's a lot of fighters that have been tripped up by emotions.
Like Donald Cerrone was on the podcast and we were talking about his fight with
date.
Diaz and Nate Diaz talked to all kinds of crazy shit to him,
knocked his cowboy hat off,
you know,
call them every fucking name in the book.
And then when they fought,
Donald was all fucked up emotionally.
He was so emotionally invested and beaten guy's ass and not losing to this guy
that he just couldn't perform at his best.
He just,
he just was so tied up.
And Conor Mcgregor,
he does that to everybody.
Yeah.
He fucks with you so hard.
By the time you get in there,
you don't even know who you are.
He's got you convinced you're a totally different person.
You'll just want to kill him and then you can't even hit him.
And it's like,
it's such a,
it's such a mind fuck when you wind up hating someone.
Yeah.
So in that sense,
it's gotta be a pleasure when you meet a gentleman like cosmo Alexander,
who's a great fighter as well.
And you don't have to think about all that jazz.
You can just,
just be yourself.
I,
I'm very lucky with this boy.
I haven't had any,
uh,
quantum and Greg is,
oh,
I,
Nick Diaz is in that of ever and all your fights,
uh,
with those,
one time I was on a television show called the contender as a French gentleman
that was sort of getting under everyone's skin and he was a token token,
a lot of smack,
but at the same time,
what was that guy's name?
Rafiq.
Rafiq him.
And then everyone was coming up to me saying,
you got to knock this plug,
can't you go and look this book out?
And then even the field cream look come and behind the scenes and oh you got all
these book yet you got to get this guy off the show.
Cause as soon as you add on as shy,
as soon as you lost,
you went home.
So,
um,
I put a lot of pressure on myself to,
and then again,
the hottie try knock somebody out,
the less it happens and then the more mentally draining you get to cause why is
that?
Why haven't knocked him out yet?
Instead of thinking,
okay,
just do the business.
And then if something lands then it goes down.
But when the harder you try,
the less it happens,
then the more frustrated you get,
then the more tired you get because you're mentally drained.
So yeah,
it's a tough gig that it's,
that's,
it's that way with everything man.
It's that way with everything.
As soon as you get emotionally invested in something like that and just you're
dealing with that other thing,
which is even bigger and more central to your,
your thoughts,
then your actual task at hand,
you're dealing with this,
like this talk,
jazz,
blah,
blah.
Which is you're going to fight.
I mean,
you're going to,
you're going to engage in the most intense form of competition ever,
and you're concentrating on this bullshit like talking bullshit.
Like what difference does it make?
What we say if we're going to fight?
Well,
the difference is if you can fuck with the guys emotions,
he can't fight.
Good.
It's crazy.
Um,
uh,
on the wane with Cosmo,
at the airport I bought myself a,
a little boomerangs,
sue a souvenir,
and then I presented at the cosmo at the Wayne and then,
um,
we,
we hugged and shook hands and took a photo with the boomerang.
And it was just that a gentleman gesture.
It's like,
oh,
well they sure ain't gonna remember me.
And then,
but then you look at the UFC and then they get the,
that Dana white standing in the middle and the Holden guys met this guy,
well,
24 hours time that you're going to punch each other in the face anyway.
So what boy,
what will the wireless acting?
And then same with them.
Conor McGregor and Eldorado,
every time they get together it's like,
well you technically you can't really do it and now you're both going to get in
a lot of trouble or you're going to get fine.
But either the commission or Dana or UFC or so just kind of,
you just be,
I know it sells tickets to,
I know it's in a test.
It's,
it's,
it's riveting.
It's so you can't,
you can't not watch it.
You can't not train into the websites and the,
and the replays.
But uh,
yes,
but he's been a gentleman sometimes can be boring compared to complete.
When you look at it like that,
it's kind of a catch 22 right.
It's like,
cause you can make a lot of money by being an Asshole,
right?
I mean,
God,
people pay attention to you.
It'd be,
it becomes,
is,
is huge media selling point.
It's a,
the story and look,
the Jon Jones,
Daniel Cormier fight,
I think,
I do believe that Jon Jones is the best light heavyweight on the planet.
And I think he beat Daniel Cormier because he's incredibly skillful.
And because he's just so good.
But I also believe that Daniel Cormier,
Aa was fucked up going into that fight emotionally because John had talked so
much shit to him.
They got in a fight at the weigh ins where they like literally we're throwing
punches at each other and they had to be separated.
It was a giant bro.
It wasn't a Wayans.
Rather it was a truck conference,
giant brawl,
the press conference knocking people over,
throwing shoes at each other.
He was madness.
But John can handle that stuff better than Daniel.
Ken.
John can still perform at the same level and under those circumstances,
I don't think Daniel did.
Yep.
Yeah.
No,
that was,
um,
that was insane.
It was great.
That was crazy.
Well,
let's just Connor too.
I mean,
part of what Connor's doing is fucking with people.
That's what Muhammad Ali,
Muhammad Ali did to Sonny Liston and Muhammad Ali first fought Sonny Liston.
They,
he was screaming and yelling at him so bad at the ins that they weren't going to
let them fight,
that they thought there was something wrong with him because his heart rate was
so crazy and his blood pressure was so high.
They were worried that like this guy is not fit to fight.
And then he calmed down.
He's like,
just relax when I was,
go ahead.
I'm,
I know what,
no fuck no what I'm doing.
I'm just fucking with this dude.
And it turned out that he knew that Sonny Liston,
although he's terrifying and he's just this massive hard puncher and knocked
everybody dead.
He was scared of crazy people.
Yeah.
And that's what Muhammad Ali did.
He just act like a fucking crazy person.
He used to drive to Sonny Liston,
his house.
He would park his car on Sonny Liston lawn and yell out at him in the middle of
the night.
Just yell at them.
Really?
Get up,
Sonny,
I'm going to kick your fucking ass.
Sonny.
He would say all kinds of crazy shit,
son and this and you ain't shit.
Yeah,
Sonny Liston.
I'm the man.
I'm the champ.
The champ is here.
It would say all kinds of crazy shit on the lawn.
Like on his fucking long.
When I was trying to sleep,
he's doing them.
Uh,
Shannon Briggs to get well with Shannon brings does now.
Yeah.
She had a Briggs hilarious doesn't mean that's champ.
Then you pay pay attention to his Instagram.
It's amazing.
I was real well,
but then that's on loop is pretty much every single beauty,
which is exactly the same.
Whereas I actually had a bit of class about it.
Oh Sam.
It was called icon is a Virginia says,
well,
Oh yeah,
the breakout,
the ramp pain.
He's like,
that's um,
that's code that,
that was pretty cool.
Yeah.
Break out the red repairs if you fight the me breakout panties.
Honey,
we haven't made it.
No,
he's here.
He's a genius.
Connor is the best shit talker ever had.
He was thinking that you're laying in bed lane and you peel anything and you
know what?
Yeah,
what color panties through my missus wave when the red ones,
the red ones are probably the best ones.
I don't even think he's thinking.
I think that's just him.
I think he just,
he just free and just,
just thinks,
just thinks that way.
You know,
he's just amazing shit talker.
He's so good at it.
Yeah.
I took,
um,
I took the hands of a bit between,
the last couple of days and he reckons he's such a good guy here.
Has Mauling camp handset.
Um,
when you talked to him one on one,
he said he's just the nicest politest gentlemen you'll ever meet.
And then you're putting in front of a stage,
especially in front of those crowds that they're pulling up the Wayne's and
press conferences.
And then he just,
he just shines and just come,
becomes as different animal,
which is a marketing geniuses at the same time too.
They're just a brilliant entrepreneur.
There's going to be set up for life.
And he wasn't like that earlier in his career,
you know,
he became like that really when he got to the UFC.
I mean,
he had a,
uh,
a,
a hair of that before.
He had a little bit of that before where he was confident and he would talk
well.
And I've been following Connor for years.
I tweeted him a long time ago,
like a several years ago,
back when he was a fighting in England,
I believe it was,
I think it was England.
I'm not sure,
fighting and some overseas organization.
And I watched him on youtube and I was like,
this guy's fucking talented.
He's talented.
He's got a clean left hand to his,
uh,
his,
his left hand power punch.
Oof.
That's a fucking good night Irene.
Punch man from this apple.
Yeah.
He,
he,
he's so good at measuring guys too.
Very good at measuring and he has a very offspeed movement.
His movement is unusual.
Very difficult to Tom.
I just want the things I was thinking about when I was watching you find unusual
movement.
You know,
it's,
uh,
very,
um,
very difficult thing for guys to deal with.
Like a lot of fighters will tell you that,
um,
sparring with a person who has a very traditional style is almost like
comforting sometimes.
But we spar with a guy who might not even be a skillful,
but it's doing things all wrong but has a lot of power.
Like does things like real,
like,
um,
the guy who just fought sugar,
Shane Mosley that crazy guy who smoked cigarettes from like a wrong yoga.
Yeah.
Ricardo [inaudible].
Ricardo,
my org is a perfect example.
When he used to fight,
uh,
the late great virgin forest,
he beat that dude because forest couldn't deal with his,
his,
his weird,
crazy punches coming from everywhere.
It was madness.
Let's punches were coming from like behind his calf and over the top and hit you
on the nose.
Like what the fuck?
Like everything was winking and wild and with murderous intentions,
it was so street,
you know,
everything it was,
it was not like skillful,
was not like fighting like a Roberto Duran who was like incredibly skillful,
but also like raw too.
You know,
with Ricardo,
my organ,
everything was awkward.
It's like you didn't know what the fuck.
You couldn't get into this rhythm.
Like when she like to very skillful boxers fight,
you know,
you,
you see,
they're looking for openings.
They're probing,
but you see like of of a common rhythm or a rhythm that
you've seen before,
you know,
it's a conventional way of moving that same in Bangkok,
you watch two professional ties in their training.
Identical.
So when you put them against each other and now you're watching the chess game
and then,
uh,
well back in the 90s,
anyway,
then you chuck in your Raymond Deco's or more.
Luckily for myself,
um,
you throwing that,
that the hands because they weren't really boxing back then.
Right.
And all of a sudden you're thrown out the rhythm because they're not,
they're all of a sudden they're like,
what the hell's going on here?
Yeah.
Ramon Dekkers used to do everything hard.
Everything hard.
Every fucking punch was murder.
Every kick was murder.
Yes.
And,
but see,
the difference between you and him was that you've fought smart enough to get to
39 years old and still confined world title fights.
Yes.
Whereas by the time he was in his late thirties,
his body had just been destroyed.
He destroyed his ankles.
Like they say that by the time he had his last few fights,
like his ankles were so bad that his doctors told him,
if you break your ankle again,
we might have to amputate your foot.
Yeah.
And so he switched his stance.
He started kicking him with his other leg,
but then the fight was to get heated up and he'd go fuck it.
And he would go right back and throw that same kick over and over again.
Just slamming the guy's arms,
slamming her knee slammed or their shin.
Yeah,
he's the guy and he's a king.
I said that last time too.
He's still looking.
I still,
I still think it was amazing man.
The Pan,
the greatest ever.
He was the man.
He,
he's someone I'm trying to implement and still,
and I said that last time too.
And Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
my whole,
every single,
every single time I have a fight,
I'm trying to emulate,
trying to walk in his footsteps to become the next team.
Say now how,
how have you gotten to 39 years of age though?
I mean with all your cuts and all that stuff,
but you don't have any injuries that have stopped you from competing at the
world class level?
Uh,
just,
uh,
luck.
Uh,
I've been so fortunate to have good genetics.
Um,
and I still had the passion.
I still wake up every morning at five 30.
I'm,
I'm on the road at six 30.
I'm still running 12 ks.
Uh,
I'm still hitting the pads just as hard.
I'm still doing messy rounds.
I had to,
for this last pip would,
I was running a hundred kilometers a week.
I ran for 10 weeks.
I worked at,
I ran a thousand kilometers for this camp.
So that's morning and night altogether.
American,
uh,
600 miles,
600 miles for the tea and the tea every 10 weeks.
That's a lot of fucking miles.
Nine rounds.
And the peds,
it sounds better.
When you say a thousand though,
it sounds Colombia I should go to meet is,
um,
uh,
nine rounds in the pads.
I was to boxing five tied,
two or three legs,
shields.
And then I'm still running with the young kids.
I'm still spinning the young guys in Australia.
I've got a couple of young gentleman's at Jake Lynn and Elliot calmed them to
come to the gym on Saturdays.
Um,
they're in their early twenties.
I'm still holding my with them and then they let the best projects.
Australia has an m and m I'm not losing.
So you think the dust because of your passion,
do you think that's because of your enthusiasm that you truly love morning time
and I know you do.
I mean it's up to you.
It's just like,
it's so exciting and invigorating and fulfilling.
And do you think that that's what happens to fighters?
Um,
first the,
the waning enthusiasm even before the body starts to fail.
Uh,
I'm not sure.
My,
I,
because I've had other students that have of,
cause I run the gym off.
I'd go as it had 30,
40 flights,
said a world beaters,
but the shoulder pops with an egos or their ankles goes and then it's not,
they have to retire.
It's not a,
not a case of that one too.
They have to where I've been so fortunate that my knees are in tech,
my shoulders are good.
My,
my,
I've had a few poems in my hands,
but no,
nothing really to stop me.
Um,
um,
surgeries of your hands at all?
Nine.
Nothing.
Honestly,
I've just had stitches,
just lots of no surgeries at lots and lots and lots of stitches.
But um,
besides that,
uh,
I'm,
I'm just so blessed that I'm gay.
And then besides good genetics and the passion that's,
um,
I just,
I just want to,
my life from the time I was four years old,
all I want him to be as a martial artist and now I'm getting older and I know
that my time is coming and I don't want to stop.
I want to ride the,
ride the wave all the way until I pass.
But I know I can't,
but I want to,
if I had my way,
I'd fight to the very day that I go to my grave.
Do you,
are you more careful now that you're 39 years old,
you more careful now about your diet,
about rehabilitation,
about those kinds of things?
I'm more more aware about losing weight before a flight.
Before I was trying to do at toy away.
I was trying to lose 10 kilos in three,
four days and now I'm doing it over a 10 week period.
So I'm only losing those last few kilos.
And the two days prior to the awake,
the Wayne,
do you think that though when you finding a really big guy like cosmo Xander who
most likely lost a shitload of water,
water weight the day before the fight and then I ve um,
re rehydrated which is legal in Moitai still not legal in MMA anymore.
Um,
at least in the UFC.
Do you think that that is,
uh,
that,
that it's a detriment to you though?
This one,
I went up a weight division also.
I usually,
if I middle what was still the boxing one 60 middle and seeing what's in the
books and weight divisions.
And this was one 68,
67,
because I was flying to America.
I didn't want to stab myself on the plane.
I didn't want to get here and I didn't want to have to put the sweatsuit on and
I didn't want a sauna,
so I only had to lose a s two kilos,
six pounds.
So there's nothing he say.
And then,
um,
and then come with come,
come way and tell I felt comfortable,
but then come fight time there for size differences.
Like oh my God,
it was different.
But it's interesting that know the one who was coming on in the fourth and fifth
round.
You know,
I mean,
I,
I wanted it.
So I,
I,
this is the,
I can't remember how long it's been since I've one of the world's huddles so
bad.
I've been very fortunate enough to win 10,
but I wanted this one because like,
like I was saying last time I was here,
um,
I want to try and reach,
I've been lucky enough to be famous in Australia
and be famous and Thailand and made my name in Japan.
But America is like the last friend here where we're at or haven't really sort
of excelled or,
or I want to,
I wanted that title to say America.
He,
this is me.
And then,
um,
and then I lost him.
Like,
ah,
but I hope I put an entertaining fight enough.
Definitely did.
How many,
how many titles does a lion fight have?
How many divisions?
Uh,
they ever,
one 61 60.
Yes.
I believe you had single Gloria holds it may.
Oh No.
Was it other young Thai kid that I forgot his what?
Possibly I think.
I think that's,
yes,
he's,
well,
he's one of the stars in lion fight.
Well,
I think,
I personally think the lion fight has some of the best skilled kick boxers in
the world today.
Yeah.
I really enjoy watching those shows mean especially they'll,
they'll bring in some ties that are just murderous.
They,
they,
they'll level of mortar that they show.
You get to see this beautiful execution of the style Purina that just fought on
this.
Any mains from Holland.
She's amazing.
She was,
and then her fight,
we're against sidewalk.
I did not hear about her until she fought Cyborg.
And then I was really intrigued to see how cyborg would fight against it.
My pure Moitai rules.
And then,
um,
the Dutch girl came and said,
who is this?
And then it's like,
Whoa,
she's a base.
There's the difference of pure and Moitai against pure MMA.
It was just,
it was a beautiful to watch the jewelry in a bar.
She has her name and she's tall and long.
You know,
Dutch people are amongst some of the tallest European,
say the average height is six feet tall and they're very big people,
you know.
And um,
your arena is like probably one of the most technical women in the world when it
comes to Moitai and that you got to see that in that fight with Cyborg.
And when,
when she pushed,
kicked her in the face and knocked her down.
I mean,
she's,
she's a beast.
She's a beast.
Do you believe it has anything to do with the,
the nutrients that are in pancakes,
pancakes,
there?
The Dutch people were like,
pancakes and smokes and biggest,
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I think it probably has to do with marijuana.
Marijuana is making the girl,
no,
I think it's just,
you know,
probably hardy people you know are hardy.
It's gets cold as fuck.
They're all the strong survived.
It's like Vikings.
Why are they so fucking big?
Like those people in Iceland that always win those a strongest man competitions.
Why is that?
Why is it all these Iceland guys to keep winning when you see them,
you go,
oh yeah,
I get it as a fucking viking.
That's a,
that's a viking that made it to 2015 with some viking genes.
They,
you know,
nothing else to do besides pick up big boulders and put them in a hundred meters
down the road.
But it's interesting what you said though about Jorena when she fought a
sidebar,
because I'll tell you what,
you know,
I was super impressed with her technique and super impressed with our skill
level,
but I was impressed with Cyborg grit and determination because she was getting
her fucking ass kicked and she hung in there and she kept trying to win that
fight.
She kept chasing that girl down and she,
and she was getting beat.
She was getting beat and she was losing and she was technically outmatched.
You know,
I think there's a difference in,
um,
someone who's really good at hitting things hard and someone who's really good
at my tie,
someone who's really good at setting things up,
you know?
And I think that what she can do better than Cyborg is set things up
technically.
You know,
and it's not the sidewalk can't learn that.
She certainly can.
But when you see someone who's used to like take downs and submissions and
dealing with little gloves and dealing with fighting people that are nowhere
near her technical level,
that was without a doubt the best striker Cyborg ever faced because she's been
fighting girls that literally there've been assaults,
you know,
you've seen a lot.
Like the toughest girl she ever fall was Gina Carano.
Yes.
And you know,
she,
that was a good fight.
It was a good fight up until cyborg started beating her down.
But the level of Moit high,
like in someone like lion fight,
like the girl who was the girl who fought into this,
uh,
this past weekend,
she's very good from check.
Yes.
Yeah.
From the Czech Republic.
All apologies,
I forget her name but she was very good as well.
Very tough.
But that was a pleasure to watch that fight cause those,
those girls were very technical,
you know,
drain and brought to the table with the Cyborg flight was,
I'm a letter frank kicks to the face,
which,
which I don't think Nma people use 'em as,
as,
as effectively because they can't use it because the catches in the takedown and
also the straight up knees because during her stay at all what,
what a normal person would throw to the bloody,
she can throw to the face,
no problem whatsoever.
So all of a sudden you have those two different elements coming at Ya.
And then,
uh,
and that's what kept leaning over and edit that kept dropping her,
especially when she was holding the ropes and taping in the corner and stream.
And cyborg was rushing in to try and knock her out.
And straight into his friend kicks.
She throws it to the body.
Well too.
She did that in this fight to that she throws that front kick to the body real
well and she follows it up with nice straight punches and she sold long.
She keeps you at the end of her punches.
Yeah,
I man,
I get frustrated when I see that more is not more popular in the United States.
I really do.
You know,
and I know,
I know I'm not the only one because the big thing that everybody always says
about MMA,
which of course I disagree with because I have a background in Jujitsu,
but that when it goes to the ground that it's boring.
I don't think it's boring because I understand what's happening and to me it's
fascinating.
I want to see like a guy like Damien Maia when he takes guys down,
strangles him.
To me that's beautiful.
That's art.
I want to,
I want to see like how he's setting things up.
You know,
when he fought Neil Magnin,
his last fight,
I couldn't wait to interview him because he made some adjustments on the ground
and took the guy's back and the guy was defending in the first,
uh,
first round.
I was like,
what adjustment did you make?
Like how did,
what did you,
and he was explaining it to me and I could see the technique and the art in his,
in his words like it to him,
it was a problem to be solved.
And that's,
I see that in Moitai too.
And I think,
um,
for um,
you know,
everybody that like the,
the meatheads that watch,
I'm a mess when it goes to the ground.
Well why don't you like my tie then?
Why is it more tie like the most popular combat sport in the world?
Cause it's all stand up.
And if you watch lion fight,
man,
you might see five,
six knockouts a night.
Like a dream killer.
Balano that fucking kid with a spinning elbow cay on his last fight.
Holy Shit.
Wild stuff,
man.
You know,
it's just,
I think also like access TV is one of those weird stations.
Mark Cuban owns it.
It's at the end of the dial and direct TV.
Can't fucking find it.
You know,
I mean,
I think that it's one of those things where somehow or another there has to be a
consciousness shift where people have to be able to appreciate it.
You know,
and I don't know what that shift is.
I don't know how to make that shift.
I don't know what it would be that would cause it to get on some big event on
television,
you know,
yachts and climb,
maybe you and yachts and Cli again,
again,
you trying to get me killed.
Come on,
get paid him.
Uh,
I was lucky.
I was very lucky at this.
The SSJ and judges,
I was lucky.
You are,
you're them.
You're too kind.
I think they're just,
I just need some exposure because what,
what of what I've realized is I'm lucky,
I think I said this last time as well.
The UFC has so good at making superstars.
And then when you,
for instance,
I'm Gloria Line flight,
uh,
you can say it's a spa spoiling us fighting,
cooking,
Saki for instance.
Amazing.
Nobody knows who they are besides the hardcore [inaudible] but um,
amazing because MMA is so big.
Everyone knows the cowboy Cerrone's everyone knows their joints ain't pas.
So when,
when they fight,
you already know the history.
You already know this guy is a killer.
This guy's,
this guy's going to talk shit,
this guy going to it's yes.
But you know what?
That's only been the case for,
for 10 years.
Yeah,
true.
In 2005,
when Stephan Bonner and Forrest Griffin fought on Spike TV,
nobody knew who the fuck those guys were.
They,
they were,
they were fighting so hard that at one point in time,
I believe the statistics was the statistic was 10 million people were watching
that fight,
which for a cable TV fight was fucking insane.
And the reason why so many people watched it is they,
they started watching it.
It was like 3 million people or something like that.
Cause it was the final spike TV.
And during the fight the numbers went up like substantially and they believe
that people were literally calling people up and going,
you've got these crazy white motherfuckers are beating the shit out of each
other on spike TV.
Go turn this on right now.
And they literally believe that it was through word of mouth during the fight
that changed MMA history because during that fight,
because it was so crazy and so wild and those guys just picked up,
pedal to the metal and went nuts for the entire fight and it was,
there were so evenly matched that after it was over,
a sport was made.
I mean it was,
sport was made by one fight.
I,
that's not an exaggeration because to this day,
although it was a great performance by Diego Sanchez,
nobody talks about Diego Sanchez versus Kenny Florian.
Yep.
Diego Sanchez fought Kenny Florian for the 185 pound title on that same night.
And Diego took Kenny down and beat the shit of him,
stopped him.
But nobody talks about that fight.
It was the fight between those two guys.
But you,
Forrest Griffin and Stephan Bonner that literally made MMA and from then on the,
the numbers just started going crazy.
Like everybody started tuning in and it just picked up and then the ultimate
fighter took off and then it picked up more and more and more and more.
And then it became a huge sport,
but it literally was born out of one event.
Yup.
Like that was,
we need something like that for Moy Tai.
We need something like that for kickboxing.
One big thing where people go,
Holy Shit.
And if that can happen,
I think in,
you also need a promoter like Dana White and uh,
you know,
owners like the Fertittas you need some,
some powerful organization has got balls and money and really gets behind it and
they need a lot of luck.
Yes.
Well that's it.
I didn't know how Kaitlyn,
I'm fucked up because,
um,
they had everything they had,
they
had the money that the TV that had the slow motions,
they had the highlights.
It had the missing fingers.
Has the dudes with the body suits the body tattoos?
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
They,
um,
they were gigantic in Japan,
they have disappeared.
It's like,
where do we go?
Where does the kickboxing go?
If I'm a young kid and I'm watching the TV,
do I,
UFC is the only only way to get,
Hey,
do you want to be a more typhoid?
Why?
Like I can be,
I can be on a,
on a cereal box or now it's gone so far that you can't be a legitimate,
um,
household name.
Whereas in Moitai,
uh,
you might get a few little medals or trophies to putting on your,
your pool room.
But yeah,
there's no,
no one driving Mercedes Benz is as a return.
There's no,
there's not even a hundred thousand dollar payday for him when he guy,
if you've,
you've,
you get 10 grand,
you're like,
yeah,
10 grain.
Yeah,
but I still got to go to work Monday.
Yeah.
And for women
even crazier,
I mean,
think about the small group of talent,
the depth of talent in women's MMA.
Like there's a perfect example.
The UFC 115 pounds strawweight champion,
you honor,
you and Jay check is a Moitai champion.
Six time world Muay Thai champion and she's just murdering checks.
Just murdering.
She's nasty.
She's business.
She is so nasty.
But other than her,
you know you have a bunch of people in her division that are really,
honestly,
there's a few with some experience that are getting better,
but they're not world championship level.
Yes.
And if you're a girl who wants to make it in fighting and you look at the pool
of talent that's in the UFC right now in the women's division,
especially 115 pound division,
you're going to be compelled to try to make it there.
Yup.
At one 35 you got that murderer,
Ronda Rousey flipping bitches on their heads and shit.
Snapping arms.
That's a tough one because she's so advanced you,
she's so,
she's so advanced that she's just smashing everybody they put in front of her.
So that's a,
that's a tough one because you would have to learn how to grapple at a very high
level to even be able to hang in there with her.
And now are her striking is getting way better too.
So it becomes problematic.
But what is the one thing that no one's ever done to Ronda Rousey?
Kicked the shit out of her legs.
Strike.
Keep her away.
Stuff to take down and kick the shit out of her legs.
We haven't seen that at all.
Like at all we've seen.
No.
How much would you like to see a world championship level Moyie Thai fighter
like Yolanda,
you and Jay check who's fighting at one through a natural one 35 who fights
Ronda Rousey.
Someone who comes out there and you see this like super high level striking game
with good takedown defense since bras.
Now you got to fight.
Now you've got some crazy shit happen.
That's what we're supposed to expect with cases that cause the Ghana.
That was supposed to happen in February.
Yeah,
but cats and Ganos not worldclass in Moitai tough.
The bill went,
then she ran into dive into your arms.
Okay,
what did you,
she's going to be laying in bed for a really long time ago.
What did I do?
Well,
cats in Ghana also you have to think as never fought in that stage before.
That stage itself is just such a mind fuck standing in that octagon,
the bright lights,
the cameras are on you and you're like,
wow.
You know what I mean?
That's probably half the reason why she made that mad,
crazy bum rush across the octagon and just wanting an attacker.
Yeah.
Um,
I heard the same thing from Therese when I was training with George.
He says,
people who don't understand that they fight in the prelims and then yeah,
because George has done it so many times.
He said you used to the pressure,
but then you get the guys that are fighting George and then all of a sudden it's
five,
five [inaudible] and the posters,
you're doing the oil,
the oil,
the media,
and then the,
the,
you have to walk out in front of that 25,000 people or whatever the MGM or
[inaudible] when he fought Toronto,
Toronto 60 say,
and you're the bad guy,
you're,
yeah.
In Canada.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
the pressure just breaks them before they even walk.
Well,
Brixton probably weeks in advance and then,
and then the day comes,
you think you can handle it.
And the day comes and then yes,
you implode on the inside or not.
Or you look Jon Jones,
you fight Shogun and your first world title fight,
you're 24 years old and you beat his ass.
He stopped them and everybody goes,
Holy Shit,
look at this guy.
I mean,
I think John was 23 actually,
now that I think about it,
he was the youngest ever UFC champion.
And I believe that Josh Barnett won the UFC heavyweight title when he was 24 so
I think I might be off by this,
but I think John was 23 yeah,
that's,
that's a special guy.
You know,
John,
just a special competitor.
And I think that for someone like Cat Zingano,
that media pressure is just as much pressure.
Having all those people ask you what's it like?
What's it going to be like when you get in there?
How are you going to win?
Who's going to,
how are you going to beat Rhonda?
What are you gonna do about her arm bars?
You know,
I mean,
think about that.
What are you gonna to better arm bar?
I'm not worried about that fucking 15 seconds.
And your arm barred dentally question the end of the equation.
Yeah.
And then you get our hard times that by 10,000 times every period of three
months prep.
It's a mind fuck yeah.
Driving insane.
But I think someone like you,
Ana who is a world champion already,
she's so used to competing at an incredibly high level and then she had to get
her bearings in the UFC.
She had that a one really tough fight with Claudia.
Good day.
Yeah.
Where it was neck and neck.
Very,
very close fight.
And then from then on she's gone to just dominate.
And I think that a woman like that,
like if you could find something like that at one 35 it would be very
interesting because although Rhonda is getting better at striking,
you very rarely if ever see her throw kicks.
It's very rare.
Yes.
And for someone who's a good Moint tie fighter man,
that is,
and also Ron has notoriously has had problems with her knees.
You know,
I think you have to find someone that can fight going backwards is because run
the charges across the cage and then anyone that silly enough to stand in front
of it and think they can strike standing on the split dead,
they're going to get taken down the straight away.
So you're gonna have to,
you don't have to be mobile,
otherwise she's going to grab you and flip it upside down.
And then when you hit an inside out and then you're also going to have to be
world class as an athlete.
And I think that she is,
but I don't think anybody she's ever fought is except maybe Sarah.
Um,
you could say,
well,
who was,
um,
not Alexis Davis,
but a Sarah McMahon who's,
was that her name?
The Olympic gold medal at the Olympic silver medalist and wrestling.
Yep.
Yeah,
she was obviously an excellent wrestler,
you know,
so you've got that.
She was at obviously an excellent wrestler,
but as an MMA fighter,
she just,
there's like some holes in her game,
you know,
and she's,
she's not very good off of her back either.
She gets put on her back and she doesn't do so well,
but I think Ron does.
She's a winner overall.
Like that's like the most important thing.
Like that person,
like the John Jones mentality,
the person who just knows how to win is not going to get rattled by the
pressure's not going to get rattled by all the hype and all the bullshit talk is
going to be able to go in there and perform at their,
at their maximum level.
Rhonda obviously can do that,
you know,
and she even said recently,
she said,
the more fucked up and crazy,
her life is more fucked up and crazy things are the better.
She fights hay,
which is just nuts.
Last flight with them,
Beth.
Um,
that,
that right hand you landed,
you don't,
you've never seen an another go look at another go with a single punch side.
That insane.
Not an MMA.
At least the only time I've ever seen that in,
um,
in kickboxing.
Well,
you know what,
Holly Holm was knocked some bitches dead with head kicks,
head kicks,
Butt Butt,
Butt,
a singer right down there.
That was,
that was nasty.
And it was nice.
It wasn't like she just a flash knockdown either.
She was,
she was out,
she was dead.
She was dating when she was hurt already.
W and then you know,
she tagged her was fucked up.
Is she tagged with the right hand then as she's going down,
Rhonda was already thrown the left.
Yep.
You know,
and the left landed two as she was,
her body was already given out.
Yes.
That was nasty.
That was,
that was a wakeup call to a lot of people that she's like learning how to strike
too.
But all with all due respect,
[inaudible] is a brawler like her technique is,
it's not that good.
She throws like kind of arm punches and she's like physically like bull doggish
you know she's tough and strong but she's not,
you know,
she's not moving like,
like yo Jay check.
You know what I'm saying?
Like she's not moving like an elite striker.
She's throwing barrages of punches and the pressure for her must have been off
the fucking charts in Brazil fighting Ronda Rousey,
talking so much shit.
And then she fucked up and talked about Rhonda is Dad and suicide and all that.
And then,
oh,
the Brazilians kind of turned on her for that.
And then at the Wayans the Brazilians were cheering Rhonda,
which never happens.
Like that's,
that's how much she's transcended.
She can go to Brazil and the Brazilians would cheer her.
I've never seen that in my life.
Wait till she eats Australia.
And she's,
um,
she's,
she's a global phenomenon.
She's amazing when she hits Australia,
I think the amount of support she's going to get there,
it's going to be off the charts as well.
It's going to be a,
and then I switched.
Holly had more fights in the UFC.
Was gonna ask Ya on the,
on the side,
what do you think about that fight?
And I think I'm a little bit early for pull Holly,
but Geez,
she's amazing books that she's still to win so many more titles in boxing and
then that head kicks a killer too.
Like,
well,
it's not that,
I don't think that Holly is capable.
What I,
you know,
one of those things I said is like,
I don't,
I don't think that's a smart fight because I want to see her fight some more
people.
I want to see her fight.
Misha Tate.
I want to see her fight,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Amanda Nunez.
I want to see her fight some tough girls and put on a show and then,
you know,
have everybody like clamor for it.
Yeah.
I believe you had mentioned the main that before.
She's,
she's,
she's a terror.
She's knocked out Sarah McMahon and her last fight,
she was awesome.
She's a beach day and you can tell she wants it too.
She's not,
she's not in the base.
The TC,
she wants that title built bad.
It is Sarah McMahon.
Right.
Am I saying that?
Make sure I'm right.
I'm almost positive I am,
but for one or for whatever reason,
I see her face in front of me and for whatever reason,
Sarah seems like I fucked up day.
I don't have too many names in my head,
man.
I really do.
Yeah,
it is right.
Thank you.
Um,
uh,
but I think Holly is physically very capable without a doubt.
And technically very capable without a doubt.
Should be the best striker run has ever faced.
No question about it.
Yes.
It's whether or not she can keep the fight standing.
She can keep Rhonda offer whether she could deal with the pressure when she goes
out there and they're 70,000 insane.
That's 10,000 more than we've ever done before.
So it's,
and it's already almost sold out.
I think it's crazy if I'm fighting main events in Albuquerque and to it to come
into Australia and fighting in front of it because footballs in the Melbourne
and to across the octagon
at that Blonde Damon coming out to that fucking Joan Jett Song,
g wised.
I don't think I've ever heard anyone call it or the the one Damon,
he's a dean.
He's no,
no question about it.
And when,
when you're locked in that thing with her and she goes after those girls,
that's a demon.
And you know,
you say after we did the podcast in February,
um,
I was lucky enough to go to the UFC hearing at the staples center and then,
uh,
we went to the lane and it was very cool.
And then,
uh,
so say Edmund and Rhonda walking down the driveway to come into the hotel.
And as a fan boy,
I had my iPhone.
I was like,
oh,
should I go ask for her phone?
I should ask her for her.
The I'll fuck it.
Why not?
And then,
and then,
and then I have,
she made I'Veh like a little scared little boy and said,
ah,
oh,
excuse me running,
you didn't want to,
if I get a picture of it.
And she goes,
oh,
sorry,
no photos until after the fight.
And then I'm Edmond Headache,
he's an arena.
And he's looked at me and then he stopped her and he goes,
Hey,
this is the guy,
this is the guy.
And she's looked at Edmond has got an art,
said this is the guy.
He goes,
this is the guy.
Say He,
he's pushed her into my arms and said,
hey,
you gotta get a photo with him.
This,
this is the Guy Admin knows who you are.
For sure.
Yeah,
he was on,
he's amazing.
So then we took a photo and then we,
she was,
she's amazing.
She's such a cool person.
I was so scared.
I was so star Trek and then I'm sure it's just normal.
And then,
uh,
and then afterwards I'll come down and got some,
a couple of drinks at the hotel bar there and Edmond was there and he made his
way over to come and have a chat to me.
And then we just talk like a week long lost friends.
He was,
he was such a gentleman as well.
He was such a nice guy.
Um,
people get,
uh,
they have,
for whatever reason they get,
there's a misconception about what he's like,
you know,
I think part of is the Armenian thing.
You know,
Armenians are so,
they're so masculine,
you know,
and they,
they have this certain way about them that a lot of people,
they misread that,
you know,
they're just,
uh,
they're fun people.
Man.
They're,
they're very proud,
very fun people.
I really,
I'm a fan of Armenians.
I really liked them because I sit in the ultimate fighter too,
so I was expecting a certain sort of presence,
but then when it was just,
he's a gentleman,
he's like,
he's,
he's awesome.
He will say cool.
And then him,
and then we just started talking about my attire and fighting.
And then I'm actually my wife who's a fight on the same card as in back in the
day when he was competing.
So,
um,
yeah,
we compete.
Where did you,
did you ever see him compete?
Uh,
they fought in the same cards here and Kelly
in Buena Park.
That's when,
you know,
you're fucked.
It's fight number.
I've just kidding.
When a park,
um,
he's,
uh,
he's done some great things with other fighters too.
Like he's really improved Travis Brown's hands,
you know,
he's done some real good work with him.
Like you saw 'em and Travis Browne's fight against Brenda's,
you saw some sharp combinations,
you know.
Um,
but then again,
he got knocked up.
Rl asked you in the fight afterwards,
but that was just chaos.
But I'd heard that like in the gym,
it's an interesting dynamic
between fighters.
Like sometimes fights,
like when you look at guys on paper,
like Travis was ranked number three in the world and our lost,
he wasn't,
you know,
a Lawsky was a guy that everybody thought was at the end of his,
his time.
But our Lasky,
it's been a worldclass.
Stryker for a long time are lost.
You'd been a heavyweight champion of the UFC,
had a nasty power in his punches,
you know,
nasty right hand and in the gym,
there's no pressure in the gym.
He could be himself and in the gym he had been used to bullying Travis around.
Apparently he had been beaten Travis up when they'd had sparring sessions.
That was what the word was.
So that when they'd gotten into the octagon together,
like for everybody else,
it was like,
man,
her laughs,
he's got a tough fight.
But for him,
he's like,
our spa,
this guy a hundred times,
I'm going to go after him.
And so they went after each other and one point Travis had them down,
man had him down.
It hurt bad and our laughs,
he came back from that and knocked him out and like that was one of the craziest
rounds in heavyweight history.
Can Matt necessarily say cool,
wild,
wild round and then a Lusk guys in flights and mia and I was expecting the same
Oleske liberal Kotlin St.
I was expecting this same thing expecting the same fireworks and unfortunately
there's a little,
it was a little bit of a look quite the same enthusiasm in that one I think in
that fight.
I think one of the things that happens in really high pressure fights,
and I think this correlates with what we were talking earlier about pressure and
about like you,
you know we were talking about guys that put too much pressure on themselves
from shit talking and get too much emotionally wrapped up in it.
When a fight is a fight where they say the winner is going to be the number one
contender,
we'll next fight for the title.
Those fights suck at least 50% of the time because at least 50% of the time
everybody locks up and nobody wants to do anything stupid because a win
virtually guarantees you a shot at the title yet.
But the fight wasn't good because neither guy pulled the trigger and it was
like,
it was very lack luster.
It's like both guys were like hesitant and,
and even our Lawsky,
even though he won the fight when I was interviewing him,
he wasn't happy gay.
He was shaking his head and he was devastated and he is crazy.
He won,
he won.
He,
he thought he was going to have the next shot at the title,
but then you know,
then the fight was bad.
So that's one of the weird things about the UFC that people don't like is if
there isn't any like clear structure.
Like when Misha Tate one,
she was virtually guaranteed shot at the title beat Jessica.
I you got a shot at the title.
She Be Jessica.
I was like,
ah,
listen.
It's the price.
It's not,
you're not ready for that.
Like why?
So she's,
she's actually,
she made some interview recently where she said that she should probably think
about what she's going to do when she retires and she should probably at least
consider that.
And I was like,
whoa.
She's like thinking about retiring.
And that's an interesting thing when you look at the number one person in the
division,
which is clearly Rhonda,
who's made,
I think she may like $6 million last year or $7 million,
something fucking crazy.
That,
and that's in fighting,
forgot about,
or all these ads she's doing,
she's in a million different fucking commercials.
I mean,
she's probably made that much on top of that with just ads and endorsements and
movies.
She's done two big movies.
She's making fucking truckloads of money.
Right.
And then there's Meisha Tate,
who's the number two girl in the division,
arguably.
I mean,
even though she's lost to Ronda three times,
she's the number two girl in the division,
right?
Yes.
And how much do you think she makes?
I mean it is,
it's a fraction.
A small,
as long as she's not hot,
she's hot as fuck.
Right.
It's got beautiful body.
Sorry,
so that,
sorry Misha.
All due respect.
But she's a great fighter too.
She's very tough.
I believe there's photos of you at the Wayne plus.
I don't know if it was her,
I think it was looking at Rhonda Zass.
I've looked at a few hours.
He kept board.
It's not a do,
I'm standing there in their underwear,
feet away from me not being a creek,
just doing my job.
Um,
but you know me,
shit probably makes it very,
very small fraction of what Rhonda makes.
And she's elite.
She's an outstanding fighter.
She's tough as shit man.
And you know,
and people love her.
It's weird.
Yeah.
I believe she's been to the movies and then as well.
His cyborg and Holly did that last one.
I've,
I'm on the Instagram and Facebook now,
but who's making that movie?
Who's going to see that movie?
What does that movie,
that movie some fucking 3:00 AM Cinemax fucking Zombie movie chicken zombies
heads off or something.
And you know,
it's like people,
when people would tell me,
oh,
he's doing movies now.
I'm like,
look,
I know a lot of people doing movies.
Like what kind of movie?
You know,
Bj Penn did if a couple of movies and we've and Gina Carano has done like,
she's done some big movies and she did that,
uh,
that one movie.
What was that movie that he was,
she was a star Haywire.
Nobody saw it.
And then because nobody saw it,
nobody gave me shit about it.
It faded away.
And then you don't hear about her as a movie star anymore.
I mean she was,
she was that close,
that close to being this runaway train movie star and this fast and the furious
and there's all the figures which she,
Rhonda was in that Rhonda was in one of those.
Right.
And then also a Deadpool,
I think that was coming out.
She just got a major part hopefully that my school I broke had a Korea.
Oh,
the ads for the or the previews for Deadpool look bad out.
It's a tough,
but my point is it's a tough racket.
The movie business is a tough racket.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I remember Frank shamrock saying to be once like he's,
he said he was going to get into acting.
He said,
well,
I'm gonna take over the world of acting the same way I took over the world of
fighting.
I'm like,
good luck with that,
dude did.
You can't even control that.
It's not like you can run hills better than anybody and kick people's asses that
you're,
when you're fighting,
you could be undeniable.
You know,
you were fighting,
they,
they lock you in that octagon or you hop over the ropes into that ring.
And when the referee says fight,
there's nothing that can save that guy.
You know,
you storm after him and knock him out and you're the fucking king.
But in the world of acting,
my God,
there's so many hoops and ladders and so much bullshit.
And it doesn't matter if you're the best from you,
you know exactly what's going on.
You've sort of enough,
I've done some acting,
but I've been very lucky to be like on the outside of it all looking in,
you know,
cause I was always a standup comic.
I always had that as my real career.
And then this acting thing was something I did when they offered me money to do
it.
If it's not something I really chased after that much.
And so when I watch other people that were chasing after it,
I got to see,
look,
the psychological aspect of it,
you see people kissing people's asses because you want everybody to like you
because you want to get cast in these movies and you got to make friends the
right social circles.
You gotta be in the right red carpets.
You gotta support the right cause.
You have to have the right political affiliations.
It's,
it's a mess,
man.
It's a fucking mess.
You can't say anything controversial.
Can't,
can't do anything too fucked up.
You know,
there's like,
there's certain things you can get away with as an athlete you can get away with
as an actor because if you did,
they would just write,
unless you're like some fucking Johnny Depp Style,
huge undeniable movie star,
you can get away with a lot of shit.
But that's just,
you become undeniable.
You have so much fan base.
Yeah,
he's already,
he's already there so he can do what he wants now.
It doesn't matter.
But even like Tom Cruise,
Tom Cruise fucked up and he started,
uh,
he did a bunch of wacky interviews where he's talking about Brooke Shields and
Scientology.
Yeah.
And antidepressants had put dude his fucking movies,
tickets,
sales ditch dropped after that.
And it took a while for them to rebound.
Took a couple of years to rebound.
Didn't help things at all.
No,
that's wacky fucking shit,
dude.
But this,
it's again,
it's that weird world of acting.
And you know,
when frank was telling me he was gonna take over that world and my chooses,
I mean,
not doubting you,
but good luck.
Hey,
that's a fucking different.
What's not the same world.
It's not like I'm going to take over the world of being a marathon runner yet.
Well,
no one can stop you there.
The,
everybody's at the starting line.
Ready.
Go.
You get an equal shot.
You're running the same road.
You're not running the same road when you're acting.
Man.
Anybody ever talked to you about doing some fucking karate movies?
John Wayne,
Paulette style kicks in,
movies.
Uh,
we've,
we've dabbled of affection but,
and leave for free.
But now he just like shorts for the Youtube but nothing for fun,
just for fun.
Yay Australian stuff or American stuff.
Uh,
after I did the documentary of the bus event and we played around a little bit
and then we went to Thailand and then I was lucky enough to work with the,
some Thai stuntman and a,
they'd work with a tiny jar and it was nice to get you guys credible.
Say they stopped him that well I got to work with um,
you,
you had thrown an inch,
a punched and each pass their face and they literally throw themselves back 10
feet onto concrete unto thee,
unto their back,
you think.
And then,
and then they lay their eggs,
they laid a Dade for three seconds,
open their eyes,
okay,
do it again.
And this time we're going to cut it in a bit shorter.
And then the term stuff again and again,
and they can't really know how to fall,
man.
Shit,
this isn't the,
I have to now they sell it,
they
make it look amazing.
It's like,
I mean the guys who far you get,
they've got to really know how to fall in up for themselves.
That's,
yeah,
a different different league.
It's like,
yeah,
I'd rather punch someone in the faces letter.
I'd rather make my money free bottlers instead of pretending to be violent.
And the documentary that you were talking about it people didn't understand you
through your thick Aussie accent,
blessed with venom and it's a great documentary and it details your life and
learning Moyie Thai and moving to Thailand and living there and fighting there.
And it's really cool documentary man.
Thanks you.
Uh,
so many people were messaging me and saying,
Jared and sent me here in the youtube comments saying thank you very much for
the,
for the Joe Rogan a the great documentary.
So it's,
it's,
it's uh,
uh,
saying before,
like when I got released in Australia,
it was lucky enough to be open in cinemas.
So we had cinema release and then,
yeah,
it just went nowhere.
So it's on youtube now.
So it'd be,
I want to have a look a bit of a bit,
not only about,
uh,
my career,
but also about Thai culture.
So I nausea,
going to Thailand and learning the Tai Customs and culture and learning how to
speak Thai and eating on the floor and sleep,
sleeping on the wooden floor and training seven hours a day.
It's pretty.
And then fighting the killers too.
I wasn't just going in there and make it up and nothing numbers.
I was lucky enough to sat at the bottom and then work my way up to winning two
world titles in Bangkok.
So it's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a happy ending.
It's a fascinating documentary too because like culturally it's such a,
it's such a unique thing for someone to do to immerse themselves in the world of
the tie and have these more tie fighters and live like they live and train like
they live.
And a guy coming from Australia and moving there and doing that,
it's like,
uh,
it's,
it's always,
to me,
amazing to watch someone just enter into a world.
It's so completely different than theirs.
And you,
you barely had a grasp at all of the language and you know,
you're training with these guys that have been essentially preparing for fights
the way they have,
the way they did it with you for hundreds and hundreds of years before you were
ever born.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
and then what happened was,
so say I've moved into this camp and there's about 10,
10 fighters there and then,
uh,
one night,
I've had my flight,
I've won,
I've gone to a patio with all the westerners hanging out,
uh,
for a week's holiday and I've come back and all the other kids that had run
away.
So then there was only me and the superstar.
So,
and now that I was giving them 50% of my prize money after every flight,
so now it was in the camps,
best interest to try and make me as as good as I could,
as fast as I could so I could win more fights and make more prize money so they
get 50% more income.
The only way that could,
the only way they could survive is for me to become the best that I could so
they could get more money,
if that makes sense.
Yeah,
it does.
That's what a fortuitous roll the dice for.
You say I was showing the under the,
under the bus,
but until the little grinder,
looking back,
it was like the biggest blessing that could happen because if there was 50
people,
then I would have been stuck in a bag by myself.
But because I was only me and the superstar,
uh,
and then the supersize sancton noise,
the he had no,
what's his name?
Uh,
he's fighting was the deadly kisser.
The deadly kiss.
Her kiss her.
So why is that?
Because there's so much gambling in Thailand.
So if he thought he was beating his opponent at the end of the round,
he'd give him a kiss on the cheek and that will show the punters,
okay,
I've got this.
So that all bid on him,
a little Betty and say,
if you're being kissed by him,
it means he's kicked your ass.
Say you did the deadly Kisa opponents know this nickname was the deadly killer
if they,
if they get,
yeah,
because after the round that Ding,
he'd walk up and just give you a kiss on the cheek.
And they were like,
what the fuck man,
you not kicking my ass.
Fuck fat people trying to take away.
They try to move away from the kiss.
I ran a deca heat.
Did he for decker three times because like,
no,
get away from me and get those filthy lips away from her.
So how did the fights go with him and decker?
Uh,
it was two.
One DECA,
Deca one,
the last one.
Now I'm saying 10 when the first two.
The first one was Japan,
the second one was on Piney,
the third one was in Holland.
Uh,
it was very,
very close.
But um,
yeah,
decker was a same thing,
was about 36,
37.
It's like me versus cosmo now.
Dang thing was a little older.
Decker was still in his prime,
so he finally got one into anytime country.
Lowe's live and tight,
tight TV and Dutch TV.
So there again making decker the,
the legend that is and how old was decker at the time?
Ah,
possibly about 34 35.
Um,
but yeah,
it was towards the end of his run to right.
It was,
he had a heart attack.
He was only like 42 or 43.
Right.
44,
44.
Four in a park.
That's what a fuck man.
How crazy.
He was riding his bike.
Right.
And he's working at Dutch park and then um,
yeah,
he has a memorial ed where they come in later,
heaps of flowers and I think,
damn that they have spray painted the,
the little tunnel that is with a big memorial of Dick Decker.
And it's,
it's um,
it's very,
uh,
what a crazy way to go for a world class athlete.
World Championship.
Kickboxer riding a bike.
Yeah.
And at a relatively young age.
He was the king weekend.
He came to Australia and he hung out with me at my gym because he was fighting a
friend of mine,
he was fighting,
he had a,
he was training a guy that was fighting,
fighting Nathan.
So they needed someone to train for the week to prepare.
So I was lucky enough they,
the promoter rang me,
said,
hey,
do you mind if rain and wind comes and trains at your gym for a week?
It's like,
oh,
yes.
So,
um,
yeah,
I hung out with the morning and night and like,
just the dude,
he was just a,
an animal.
Uh,
and so many stories like me,
I knew I could just sit here and just listen to you all day,
like a little school boy,
just asking stories,
what's about this?
What about that fight?
Do you have any injuries?
And then he'd just go on it.
He just,
it was,
um,
just a little boy just listening to greatness.
So it was,
it was,
um,
it was really cool.
He gave me a pair of shorts that I have up on my gym that a,
I'm so proud of,
important and multiple times in.
Uh,
but yeah,
just,
um,
the wars,
he's a [inaudible] pretty much.
He was in first,
the first one to put it on the map,
the to say look there a possibility for white
people to beat ties it their own sport in Thailand at the big stadiums and that
not only wind but knock him out in devastating fashion.
So his style was so aggressive to God.
It was so exciting to watch.
He's one of my all time favorites.
And then rob came in.
It was different because rob was a bigger guy.
Yes,
yes.
But very technical.
God,
he has such a system.
I had the honor of training with him quite a bit and he's so technical man,
his system,
he has such a system for,
for a Muay Thai,
you know,
for kickboxing,
for putting combinations together and you know,
and placement and movement.
And he's a fucking interesting guy.
Rob came in,
Matt,
very interesting guy.
It was hard for him to get the same accolades as Raymond because Raymond was
fighting the ties at their most craziest,
wait that [inaudible] 63 to 61 to 63 so whereas whereas you say that you mean
kilos,
which is like what does that work?
One 35 one 40 or something like that
and then a where's where's,
rob was a little bit bigger when he was fighting and toys a little bit smaller.
So he was knocking them out.
But at the same time he should have been knocking him out because he does it.
And then when you're fighting western of US western or you're not going to get
the same worldwide sorta.
Whereas Raymond was his fighting like the pure killers at a day at their weight.
And I'm not just beating him but knocking them out.
So,
and then when the Po,
when the tires are paying attention and the country stopping to watch a western
or come to their country to,
to,
to knock out their their best,
then you know you've made it.
Yeah.
He was a real phenomenon and for,
and that's one of those things that for people that don't know the sport or
aren't aware of it,
like you can go right now to youtube and go on a journey through the world of,
of one of the greatest combat sport athletes ever.
And Ramon Dekkers has so many fights on youtube.
You can go and watch them and you'll understand what we're talking about when
you just watch to that guy just slam those kicks in and the attack with a
barrage of beautiful punches.
He was a monster and the monster,
these pressure to hidden push guys into the corner on unto the ropes.
And then it wouldn't matter if he got hit 14 times in the way and he just give
me one,
give me one bang,
Bang,
and then boom,
and then just knock him out unconscious.
My style is so hard.
It was such a hard style.
He,
he did a seminar at my gym.
It was,
um,
he said,
just have three or four of us.
We just keep it tiny.
We just keep it really small.
That's what he wanted.
The emir four person seminar,
he didn't want,
he didn't want the big 100 people.
He just said,
good,
let's keep it six people max.
Wow.
He said,
let's keep it an odd number so I can join in.
So many took it turns the gun at one by one with this and then he'd say,
okay,
put your hands up.
I'm going to demonstrate a demonstration.
And he'd go,
one,
two Hook Lake and then you think,
and he's going to tap and it's like boom,
boom,
boom and then chop and then your eyes would go,
bink,
what the hell was that?
And then it sort of look at me as if it was,
he was shocked that he hit me so hard.
It my reaction.
He goes,
what?
I said,
ah yeah,
that was crazy.
He goes,
Oh,
in Holland this is normal.
This is what we do.
Because on the ring there's no surprises.
So if we train like this on the ring,
this isn't an,
I'm just looking at him,
gone to,
there is no way in hell I'd like to train with like this.
Especially everyday for a couple of hours every single day.
They'd be detrimental to them through my health.
Well ultimately is do you think that that's part of what broke him down?
Like as he got older,
like he was devastated.
Like physically by the time he was done,
his ankles were gone.
Yeah,
possibly.
Possibly.
And I think you've got to the stage where he's buddy was so destroyed where he
can only do pads.
He couldn't even,
um,
I don't think you would spa.
I remember him telling us at lunch,
he said,
hey,
I just do pads,
pads,
and then was,
and again,
because he was fighting so regularly,
he didn't have the spy because he was following up with possibly every two weeks
or so.
So yeah,
he was,
um,
yeah,
I did sit,
that's the eternal debate because like in,
in MMA as well,
Joe Duffy was supposed to be fighting.
Dustin poray this past weekend in Ireland in a huge card in Dublin,
sold out in like an hour,
just Irish love fights.
Right.
And Joe Duffys,
the last guy to beat Conor McGregor,
and he's an Irishman.
So everybody's excited to see him.
The Saturday before the fight,
a week before the fight,
he gets a concussion,
a yeah.
Sparring,
hard sparring,
hard going out for it,
you know,
and um,
they pull out of the fight.
So he pulls out of the fight the week of tried to,
you know,
they,
they gave him some examinations and the doctor looked at him and said,
listen man,
you,
you got fucked up.
Like you need a lot of time off.
You need a few months off,
you can't fight.
Yeah.
Accounting backwards from 10 apple,
orange,
lemon.
So when you,
that's the eternal debate.
Do you spar like the Dutch,
do you fucking go crazy?
Like Melvin Manhoef and Mike's gym,
you know,
you just fucking attack,
attack,
attack and just take your lumps and deal with it and just,
and then when you fight,
you will fight like that because you finally that all the time or do you take a
more intelligent approach?
Like many fighters do,
like the ties to where they spar and they don't spar harder.
All right.
All the toys.
Then even when I first got there,
there was no shin pads or,
um,
yeah,
it was nice.
It was just,
it was,
and then you'd could almost sweat bag meets,
you know,
it's just te,
te,
Te,
and then you're just working on movement nation peds,
Amy Shit on Shane.
It's still be fast.
And then you pull out that light,
like karate,
letting put karate style,
but there was Thai boxing and then,
um,
you still know if he got,
got,
got or not say if,
uh,
the Shin Land and across your ribs,
it'd be pulled.
We just a tap.
And then,
um,
and then you'd get spoiled with the kids that were 10 years old and saying,
do a nation peds.
And then no one got hurt.
And then after three hours,
you're still smiling and still joking.
But you've learned so much.
You've learned it.
You just got your ass kicked by a 10 year old without getting beat up,
if that makes sense.
When we box,
when we box,
we spy about 80,
90%.
But when we,
when we,
when we kick and play in and in the clinch,
uh,
it's a bit more control over the Clinton is harder.
That is I suppose.
But,
um,
longevity as you can do that in a clinch,
the same like Jujitsu,
you can go full blast and you don't have to worry about it cause you're not
striking each other.
Yeah.
I've had,
um,
122 flights now.
That's fucking crazy.
I'm sweet.
And then I've,
boy listen to you,
Lee,
you're talking,
you're fine.
You know there's no,
there's no dementia,
there's no slurring words.
Have 122 boxing fights.
Yeah,
Jesus Christ.
Um,
so,
uh,
and then you hear about MMA guys and then if they have more than 30 flights,
it's a big,
it's a big deal.
But yeah.
Let's see.
And then Jeremy Horn had over a hundred fights,
but very intelligent fought,
real smart,
very bright guy,
very technical,
didn't,
it's not like an athletic,
powerful,
super,
you know,
freak athlete.
Everything he had to do was proper technique and intelligence.
And to this day over a hundred fights,
Jeremy Horn,
like you would never know it talking to him or looking at them,
you know,
he looks great.
Talks Great.
The majority of the ties I've had uh,
two two 50 flights and then,
um,
yeah it's just normal.
It's 255 times fucking crazy.
We had a 10 year old kid in the eye camp that had a hundred fights as a 10 year
old.
He'd,
he'd flight Monday,
Tuesday rest Wednesday,
fight Thursday,
said they possibly rest Sunday and then every time you fight he is making 500
bucks,
500 bucks.
So then he's parents didn't have to work almost.
He was making enough money as a junior fighting four times a week,
five times a week where he could support the family just as,
as a,
as a 10 year old say,
say,
yeah,
it's,
so for them over there,
it's a 10 year old.
I said,
if you're at 25 kilos to you're not working with a hundred percent Perry that
you your score and you're playing the game.
Yeah.
It's not until you get into your,
your 13,
14 and then you start using a bit more forced and you're excited to get me on
with damage on the shins in a bit more.
Um,
you gotta be a bit more wary of punching payer.
But as a,
as a junior from say seven to 10,
you can definitely get away with fighting three,
four,
five times a week.
No problem.
Well,
some people say that that's the best way to teach kids to because they learn
before they can hurt each other.
Yes.
And you learn like how to move properly and your body develops like that.
You know,
your body develops.
Like there's people that are um,
that started out like to have like a martial arts background when they were
young and then they started putting on weight,
like muscle weight.
But there's still,
it's super flexible and it's because their body sort of developed throwing kicks
and their body develop doing those motions.
And if you can learn,
like there's a lot of people that believe that as as a boxer,
that if you don't start when you're young,
you'll never achieve like a Floyd Mayweather level or Roy Jones Jr level.
Like it's not possible.
They say it's not like your body has to develop doing that in Australia.
There's a big controversy right now because the athletic commission and the
government's and there,
they're all talking,
they're talking and they don't want juniors to compete in any form of combat
sport whatsoever until the age of 18 which I,
which I think is ludicrous because if that happens,
you've got the rangers,
the rest of the world that have already excelled to a certain level and if we
don't start competing to 18
we're already behind the eight ball.
We've,
we're so far behind that,
but that's so ignorant.
That's ignorant on their part.
People don't understand combat sports because that's the time to learn.
Yes,
yes,
and then,
and then it's also,
you're not learning it.
It's not about the flight.
It's about the culture.
Yeah.
It's about the lifestyle.
It's about living healthy and training and training the body and getting
flexible and getting over the fear of getting in competition as well.
It's about experiencing what young people are terrified of getting your ass
kicked and I'm experiencing it in the gym.
Right.
My daughter was lucky enough this,
that fighting at the age of eight.
And it's hilarious how many people say that my daughter was lucky enough to
start fighting at the age of eight.
And then,
uh,
from the,
I remember she walked in as,
as a,
as a little baby girl and I was,
I was so petrified as a father,
but then she walked out like a woman.
She walked out as a warrior,
as eight year old warrior.
And then ever since she's had this passion for the fighting.
She loves collecting trophies.
She loves making,
um,
magazines and doing interviews.
And uh,
it,
it makes you a bit,
become a better person,
I believe.
I think it,
it makes your evolve evolves where it would,
it definitely,
um,
people had never fought.
We never understand what it's like to,
to have that bond against someone to compete for a couple of minutes.
And then after that,
no matter what happens,
I've always with 122 people,
I can say,
um,
I'm not just a friend,
but I have,
I've shared a moment in time where me and you,
we've,
we've went into a different dimension for that,
that time that we fought each other.
Does that make sense?
Does that,
it does mean that,
you know what I mean?
There's nothing they can erase that memory of me and you,
um,
the standing toe to toe and exchanging blows.
So yeah,
I think that,
yeah,
this is why I love the sport so much because I have such a deep passion for it.
Well,
when I was watching that cosmo Alexander fight,
I was actually thinking that I was like,
these guys,
are they sharing a crazy cause I was also thinking like,
you're 39 years old and I don't know how much longer you can compete at this
elite world class level.
You know,
you're fighting in a world championship fight.
And I'm watching this,
I'm like,
man,
this is a,
this is an intense moment that these two guys are sharing.
And afterwards you guys were smiling and hugging each other and I was like,
wow,
those guys really did just share a very,
very intense experience and a very intense moment that very few people will ever
understand.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
yeah,
it's actually there.
And then to,
to erase that from childhood memories for young kids not to have that
experience.
I think that's so sad because,
um,
what's better,
especially coming from myself,
if to go to school on the fighting on,
said they in the tournament and go to school on Monday and tell him the boys,
um,
I,
yeah,
I've got a gold medal for whatever competition that you split.
Obg Judo,
Jujitsu,
taekwondo,
karate.
It doesn't matter if it's more,
it could be anything.
It's an oil,
even soccer,
football.
It,
you've,
you've gone out in the weekend and you've excelled at that sport that you've,
uh,
um,
put your life into.
So,
and that the boys come over to house,
they have a sleepover.
You got four or five trays up on the shelf,
nothing can make you more proud than,
than to be in there from my fighting days.
So I think it also teaches you how to overcome very scary moments and very
difficult moments.
And I think when you don't overcome difficult moments,
you always have that fear.
Like how,
how would I do under pressure?
What would happen to me under PR?
I mean how would I do when the chips are down,
when I'm nervous.
I mean,
and people who compete,
they have the experience of doing that.
And I think that's where characters built characters built through adversity.
And I think to deny young kids the opportunity that,
especially out of ignorance because if they don't,
they don't understand that young kids don't get hurt the way adults do.
And you're fighting like you know,
you see a guy like a gold con Saki fight and Tyrone Spong,
those are big boys,
big heavy throwing guys that are throwing fucking bombs.
There's a big difference between that and two six year olds that are fighting
Moitai with headgear on and the gloves and,
and,
and Shin pads in an amateur fight.
What those kids are doing is they're learning how to do something that's very
difficult.
Yes.
And that is the same coming that,
uh,
that moment,
that same,
the same fee,
but with the protection.
So it's almost the same.
I like what you said on the,
I have eye shade one,
a yield quotations on my Instagram the other day.
They absolutely killed it about,
um,
people that have never been in a street fight.
Um,
it's that same thing.
Where have people that are,
you'll always say,
ah,
that glide pieces,
these pieces of me off of,
I'm just going to knock him out.
And it's like,
no,
you're not.
You have no idea if that guy hit you back.
You know how much it's going to hurt.
Well,
what I said was that I don't understand how people who have never had any
martial arts experience at all are willing to fight.
Yes.
Like they're crazy.
Like they're fighting.
And I've seen people fight in the streets that you could tell when they're
fighting,
that they have no fighting experience at all.
They don't know anything,
and yet they're willing to take a chance and fight.
Some guy they don't even know and they're going to somehow or another,
they think they're going to kick this guy's ass like you don't even know.
You don't know anything.
It is
just flailing.
I've seen it happen.
It's,
it's terrifying.
I don't understand it.
I don't know how people are willing to do that so mad right now I'm just going
to go walk over the Amgen.
Lucky man.
It's not that.
It's not that easy.
And then,
and then once that confrontations thoughts,
if you hit that person and then you don't knock him out,
you're just going to piss him off or you break your hand.
How many times did people don't not throw a punch and hit a guy in the forehead
and just smash your hand open?
Oh,
they,
they pull it out and then they break a bottle.
They pull something out of the pockets of Christ.
Then it gets this Nixon level,
it's life or death now.
Great.
You don't know how to fight at all.
And you're in a life or death situation where you just hope this guy doesn't
kill you.
You know?
Let's hope somebody that rescues you beforehand.
It's terrifying,
you know?
Especially because the different,
there's a,
there's a big difference.
And I think that's where a lot of people get confused when it comes to martial
arts and the equated with violence,
the,
the competition of a fight or have a,
an event like a,
a martial arts event is very,
very different thing because you're preparing for a skill contest and the skill
contest may be dangerous and there's a Po,
there's possibly violent endings to these things,
but it's not violence in the sense of you're not like trying to go out and find
someone and make them your victim.
What you're doing is you're trying to compete,
you're competing.
And in doing so,
you learn something about yourself and you develop a confidence that for someone
who's never competed like that,
it never totally understand.
Yes.
If violent game of chess.
Yeah.
And even more crazy than chess,
especially MMA because there's so many more,
there's so many moves.
There's so much going on this like if you,
if you're playing chess,
you have so much time to think about it unless you're playing that speed chess
shit where they're hitting the clock.
But when you're playing chess and you're overlooking this board,
I mean not taking anything away from chess because chess is a fascinating game
and there's so much complexity to it and there's so many different moves,
so many different possible combinations.
But believe it or not,
there are more possible combinations and fighting.
There's more possible combinations.
The outcome is more terrifying.
More is at stake.
Your physical health is at stake.
You're gambling your health on discipline.
You have to get up in the morning,
you're,
you have to overcome your body being tired and sore and you got to get up when
you don't want to.
When that warm bed is calling you,
you got to put on your fucking running shoes and you've got to go do your
roadwork and you've got to do your strength and conditioning and you've got to
spar.
When you don't want a spa and your body's starting to get run down and you've
got to make sure you get the right amount of sleep.
You got to make sure you're getting the right amount of nutrition.
There's all these variables,
emotions,
the,
the physical fear,
the fear of your own demise,
not the nerves of a,
I'm sure chess players get nervous before they have a match,
but do you think they get nervous the way a fighter gets nervous?
I don't think it's possible.
And they'll have to go in the hospital after then.
Yeah.
And then there's no fear or am I going to get looked at and I'm going to cut,
uh,
when I compete,
I tried to tell people that are coming up through the sport.
Ah,
what's it like to have your first fight?
It's,
it's luck was him before he,
once that the bill rings,
everything goes numb.
And you don't have time to think,
so you have to take yourself.
Everything's on that muscle memory.
So say many times I've been punched or keep that or an elbow is shown and I've
blocked it with a quarter of a second ago,
and I'm thinking in my Haiti,
if that had a hit me flush out would have been knocked out.
But I'm somehow,
rather than when my body knows the blocking time to camera and time and then I
don't hear anything,
I don't see anything besides my opponent.
Uh,
I can't,
uh,
yeah,
just in this different world.
And then the end,
the end of the book,
the fight,
the bell rings Ding and all of a sudden it seems that the world opens back up
again.
I'm back on the chair,
I can hear voices again.
Uh,
and then I can't remember the fight.
The fight is just a blur.
Um,
it's like Toby was a Haiti,
remember this or that or til you watch the replay on the,
on,
on the phone
or the internet or the replay.
But um,
it's it,
yeah,
he just,
you into a different realm completely.
It's such a unique experience to,
to,
to turn off your brain and just rely on pure instinct as a,
it's a,
it's again,
that's why I love it.
I love it so much.
It's going to be an intensity that no one else could ever understand.
And that's probably a bond that you share with those people that you get into
the ring with,
like Cosmo Xander,
that the average person would just never be able to understand what you guys
have gone through.
Yeah.
And then the idea you've been cut and you can the one eyes blurry from the blood
and you,
and you don't want to wipe it because that's a tale from your opponent,
the bloods that no noise.
So you've got to try and stay there with one way or red and bloody and Yucky.
And you can feel a stickiness in your eye,
uh,
and you can feel the pain,
you can feel your eyes throbbing and then you've got to turn off a,
it's such a,
you got to take yourself as such in that you've got to go so much soul searching
to keep focus on,
on being violent.
And trying to win no matter how,
even though you're losing,
you know that you have to like try and come back and still still knock this guy
out and make adjustments and make adjustments and just turn the pain off.
Yet still trying to focus on how am I going to this,
what I'm doing is not working.
So I have to try and up the ante and try something else and that might get me in
more danger again where I might get even more cat or my or more beat up or
another need of the face.
So do you ever work with a hypnotist or a psychologist or a sports psychologist
or anything?
Uh,
I know,
uh,
Vinny shoreman I,
I'm good friends with any,
but I never worked with anyone I know.
Try with Vinnie Vinnie's I was,
I was wondering,
I was like,
what is this?
Yeah,
hypnosis and Vinny put me under,
yeah,
I knew I was under,
but I was like,
Whoa,
this is a strange state.
He puts you in.
He's a very interesting cat.
Then he's been,
he's cool.
He came out to Australia with a friend.
And where any Alison and then,
um,
there were hanging out for a week and we were good buddies.
But,
uh,
and then in Australia as well,
there's a lot of mine coaches as well that I've noticed that of setting to a
period of somewhere.
But because I'd been in Thailand so long,
I don't believe I need mine coaching.
I believe I'm already at that stage in my life where I know exactly what I want.
Same with this world title with Cosmos.
I know I wanted it.
I didn't need someone to tell me that I wanted it.
I know I want it and when I lose it,
I'm just fucking pisses me off.
But I think,
um,
a lot of people have that thought about what it is.
And I've,
I did as well,
like,
oh,
well what you're gonna do is it's going to solidify what you want and you go
after it.
I don't necessarily think it's that what Vinny instead of hypnosis,
what Vinny likes to think of it as like you're optimizing the pathways for your
focus.
And instead of like saying,
I know what I want,
I'm gonna go get it.
It's sharpening that to a razor's edge.
And I think that,
um,
I think you should,
I think everyone should look into it and not,
and not necessarily saying that everyone should implement it.
Like,
like here's a perfect example
of like Roy Jones Jr in his prime.
How would say just do everything you're doing.
Don't change a God damn thing.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean when he was fighting and just moving like no one has ever moved before
knocking guys out with combinations that were just ridiculous.
Like how could you say that guy needs to go to a mind coach?
You can't write.
But I really honestly believe that even though I would say just do whatever
you're doing,
if he did go to a mind coach,
it would probably take it to an even different level.
Probably take it to an even higher level.
I think that everything you do,
everything you do is good.
As you're doing it,
you could do it better.
I think everything can be optimized,
you know?
And I think everything has layers and levels to it.
And to say,
this is good enough,
this we're done here.
I just think honestly it almost like it disrespects the process of evolution.
It disrespects the process of,
of getting,
getting better at it of greatness.
Like for every Roy Jones Jr there's a guy watching Roy Jones Jr and thinking
I've got to figure out a way to beat that motherfucker and training harder and
maybe he has just as many physical gifts and maybe he has just a slight edge in
some sort of a weird,
strange way because he's been watching Roy Jones jr compete.
I mean,
I don't know man.
I think that this sport is all about like minute differences,
like all combat sports.
Just like I do,
you know,
nick curse on his strength and conditioning coach,
really a highly,
highly respected trains.
Um,
Hofeld dos Anjos who's the UFC lightweight champion and trains a rustle on
providing a cough,
a famous boxer and bunch of other elite athletes done some work with Joe
Schilling now too,
was doing some work with Joe Schilling.
And,
um,
he said something really interesting when,
Hofeld dos Anjos beat Anthony Pettis and he said,
you know,
one of the things that we did with him,
um,
these,
uh,
all these,
strength and conditioning drills,
it's about executing and getting there just slightly faster.
And he's like,
even though he dominated that fight,
think about those exchanges.
He dominated those exchanges by maybe a half a second.
Like he landed a half a second quicker.
He was a half a second.
What were is recovery was just a little quicker.
He was able to reengage just a little quicker.
And those little tiny edges,
there's little tiny edges means he lands first and it means he's dominating.
And even though his advantage,
like physically his advantage of execution was so small,
it was enough.
Those little advantages are enough to win a fight.
And it's incredible when you think about it that way,
that this sport is just,
it's a matter of like these incremental increases in ability,
incremental advances.
Yeah.
So fascinating to me.
I never grow tired of it.
I guess I'm sort of a,
an the cavemen era to where I believe that I think what they're the mind coaches
are doing awesome.
But at the same time I don't need someone in the pat my back and say,
hey,
you're doing a good job.
Right.
Okay.
I had him doing that though.
Yeah.
I don't think they're doing a talk to Vinnie.
I mean maybe,
maybe he give you a bit of an insight on it,
but I think you're right too.
You know,
I'm not saying he's right and you're wrong.
I think you're right too,
because you're a proven champion,
you know,
and that mindset,
the steely determination that you've developed,
like nobody needs to tell you how to do it.
You know,
I,
I firmly believe you're one of those guys.
You could wake up at three o'clock in the morning and say it's go time and you
put your shorts on,
wrap your hands and you know,
what the fuck to do.
You just kind of fall into it.
You know,
it's your thing.
It'd been doing it forever.
I cause there's a gentleman in Australia that's doing it.
And then if someone's having a bad day on it,
they call him and say,
Oh man,
I had a bad session.
What do I do?
Don't worry.
Tomorrow's a new day where I know,
okay,
today I fucked up.
Tomorrow I'm going to,
I'm going to train harder and make sure that it doesn't happen again.
Yeah,
you're on mind coach.
And then I let no one else to blame but myself too.
So I'm very lucky in Australia that I owned the gym.
I'm on my own train and my manager,
I do all my own Nigga negotiations with uh,
promoters.
Uh,
I have my friends that come in like Kevin from New Zealand here that comes and
helps me.
Uh,
and we,
we work on different,
we talk,
I give him ideas of what I want to do on the pads.
Uh,
so,
so everything I'm,
I've,
I'm in control of my own destiny,
if that makes sense.
I've got no one dictating me what to do.
I'm not,
I was the one that reached out to Scott can try and get in line for,
I'm the one that's reaching out to all these different guys.
So you like that,
but some people don't.
Right.
Some people like they're,
they just don't want to train.
They don't want to thank,
they want their manager to tell him who the fight.
They want everything set up for them and they just want to concentrate on
training.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
Well cause I've finished toilet.
When I moved back to Australia from Thailand there was,
there was no one for me there.
So opened a gym because I needed somebody to train.
So I had to teach classes to pay their rent so I could still have somewhere to
train and that sort of blossomed into the gyms that have been successful.
So then I started having more guys trained on the meeting and they wanted to
fight.
Then all of a sudden I'm working their corners and learning how to wrap hands
and,
and now I'm trying to do everything and then also at the same time and trying to
create my own career as well.
So I've been,
yeah,
so lucky then.
Yeah,
there's just,
it's just what happened.
It's not that I wanted,
like I wanted a coach.
I'd love to have a coach,
but at the same time it's what I've been doing.
It's been working and I've been lucky enough to be successful.
So where would you train if you,
if you didn't have to run your school and if you didn't have to wear,
is there a place in the United States or in Thailand or anywhere in the world
where you would train titled Thailand was perfect for them for five years and
then,
uh,
definitely definitely grew out of that.
And when it was wanting to come to Australia was perfect and then put,
where would I train you grew out of it.
How so?
Uh,
the,
the flights were so high for so small money,
so,
so high level fides,
very dangerous,
very dangerous flights.
Again,
guys with 200,
300 fights and then your prize money is enough for a happy meal.
It was crazy.
And then by the time you convert that happy meal,
money to Australian money,
um,
yeah,
you're buying a pack of chewing gum.
Sam,
what's the cheapest you ever fought for the cheapest?
I fought for was 1000 bucks,
which was $25.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
But then you have to pay money to the gym and then you got to think about
training expenses and food,
even losing money,
a lot of money.
So yeah,
it sort of sucks.
But then I worked,
I worked my way up and then my last fight in Thailand was for 1 million bucks,
which was approximately 35,000 Australian.
And then,
uh,
that's not bad.
Right.
If that's okay.
It was probably like super elite worldclass fight.
Yeah.
And then from there,
I've been on the under thirties or forties for the last 10 years.
So I've been very fortunate that way that I've,
I've enough to survive and live comfortably and I only have to train and look
half of the gym.
And,
uh,
we're a lot of other people that I manage.
And then,
um,
if they're lucky,
if they get $3,000 is they've hit the jackpot.
It's such a hard sport to try and become a superstar.
It's so hard.
So there was one place where you would train if you had,
you know,
it was totally up to you,
I guess.
I guess Holland,
Holland.
Well,
how long do you know?
Good question.
I'd probably trained,
we call him his core hammers is a sketch and he's got the writing on the wall,
the board with,
um,
Raymond and then,
uh,
I was the gentleman now that trains at a glory and there's doing this Kim,
Nikki Holson and I'm not sure,
I'm not sure he's,
he's with call him and say he was for a while.
I wasn't off.
He is anymore.
I believe he's still with that,
that circle of guys.
He's amazing.
He's excellent.
He's one of my dream flights.
I,
I'm a probably a little bit older,
40 now because he's in his peak and I'm a little bit older,
but he was one of the guys that it's always,
I always thought that we'd cross paths,
but we never did he see,
um,
he's glory 76,
I believe.
Oh,
[inaudible] 77.
Uh,
Georgia's weights.
Walter.
Okay,
so it's one 70.
I believe so.
Yeah.
So He's,
yeah,
he's a little heavier,
a little more like cosmo Alexander Cosmos in a kill it too.
He just got dynamite.
Uh,
it has to left talk nasty,
nasty punches just like,
just like Raymond.
I'm very similar to what we'll use.
Is Raymond Deca mini me so well he has a very tactical style over intelligent,
you know,
like when he fought Raymond Daniels,
good high knees will need of the faces and killer,
but he fought Raymond Daniels,
Daniels throws all those wild combinations and crazy shit.
You know,
just walked them down,
figured out,
keep the pressure on them,
throw a lot of leg kicks,
throw combinations,
rip that left hook to the body and eventually took them out.
And once he presses him into the corner too,
there's no escape.
And he's got,
he's got that nice switch knee to the face.
And the Raymond Daniels is an interesting case.
He didn't,
do you know who he is?
Yes,
he's wise.
They fought twice and he stopped in both times.
You know,
Raymond Daniels is an interesting case because there's a guy who was at leat at
a very odd style of fighting.
He was elite at point karate and if you watch his point,
karate fights online,
you realize like God it's guy just blitz is in with this crazy shit.
And then they would stop it and point cry for people don't know is like a really
high level game of tag with karate because once you touch the guy,
like literally touch them,
they stop it and they score the point.
So it's very difficult to transition from that into continuous fighting.
Like when you fight in kickboxing or Thai or an MMA,
when you hit a guy,
once he hits you back,
you hit him again and it's all about hitting and not being hit and movement.
What,
what karate would they get really good at is this blitz where they jump on you
and to attack,
but they have to get used to hitting back and the referee not stopping the
action.
So credits or Raymond Daniels,
he went from doing this one style of like jumping in and hitting a guy once to
this continuous stock and then also factor in leg kicks.
Cause in these karate tournaments you can't kick the legs.
So he's jumping in with all these wild kicking and punching techniques and then
he goes from that to this incredibly difficult,
grueling style of fighting.
The guys have their hands up very high.
The throwing a lot of leg kicks and,
and he's excelled at it except at the very elite level when he's fought the very
best guys like Joseph optoline stopped him.
Same thing,
attack the legs,
attack place,
get them to block the leg goes up high,
it head kicks him.
But it's utilizing the Moy Thai style to defeat this style where he just,
he's got so many tools,
but it doesn't quite have all of it together at a world class level.
Let the guy fight on the outside,
man,
he's got that blitz blitz in those wild kicks.
He's really interesting.
Yeah.
Very Unorthodox edits.
The spins.
Yeah.
And the jumping,
but you've got to wonder man,
man,
with a guy with those type of skills,
if he could get his hands at the same level as like a niche Niki holds can or a
valine and get those leg kicks at the level that those guys have,
like,
Ooh,
you man.
Yeah,
no,
it's crazy.
He's um,
yeah.
Yeah.
But then Nikki Holsten,
he's a,
I don't know how anyone can fight him right now.
He's probably the the king at that weight division.
Yeah.
There's,
so there's a lot of talent and glory.
It's a really drives me nuts to seeing,
seeing that them leaving spike TV,
I'd really bums me out.
I don't know what's gonna happen now because the without them and the prize
money we had the again and B that they exposure where what happens now,
what happens to the lion fights.
They're only channel to go near like I suppose.
And their ability is doing the kickboxing version as well with their last show
with the ring in the cage.
So that was interesting.
And that was combined with glory.
Yeah.
I suppose.
Yeah,
I think that that was what they were doing.
You know what I mean?
They were just trying to have like a big crazy like Japanese style event,
you know?
I don't know
man.
It just bums me out.
It just bums me out that it for whatever reason it didn't catch on.
Yup.
You know,
and spike is obviously where the UFC took off.
So it's not like it can't happen there,
but whatever reason it just didn't.
Yeah,
I say,
yeah,
it's hard.
It's hard.
It's hard for us.
Strike is we um,
Eh,
have they get the Steel Cup on the corners in between flights?
They didn't Tingler Jean,
any good need change?
Pass the hat around.
What about in Holland?
Is,
is it they make money at Holland fighting,
I believe.
Uh,
they shut down all the big shows as a massive show called showtime with,
well,
half a football stadium and I believe that had like 30 to 40,000 people that
would come to these events three or four times a year.
And then apparently the hell's angels were involved with a little bit of
Washington washing this and that.
And then,
um,
they got banned from doing the big shows.
So that's why there's nothing happening in Hollindale.
Yeah.
Again,
again,
it was that that was the place to go.
Hollen and showtime and Cosmo was a former showtime champion also in about a
hiree love.
Watch that.
He's fucking crazy.
Send me shield or crazy killers.
All the Dutch.
It was such an amazing show.
And then because they're knocked on the head now there's,
where do you go?
They'd like that was the,
besides,
um,
Thailand.
Holland was at that place and now,
now that's dried up.
Now it seems that maybe Japanese can fucking pick up the slack and come back
with k one again.
Cause I know they're trying to do a new MMA promotion.
They have fade or for new years.
Yes,
but here's the problem.
There's no heavyweight talent out there that can't find fate or an opponent.
Someone said he's opponents for flights or something with two.
Well that guy,
they pulled that guy out.
Apparently he's not in shape.
That was,
that was,
uh,
an Indian gentleman,
I believe from India.
I don't even,
I know who he is,
but he's not,
he's just not world class.
It's not,
not for a guy like fate or like,
you know,
you're talking about arguably the greatest heavyweight of all time and you're
going to have him fight a guy who's just nowhere near his league for a New
Year's eve show.
That's crazy.
You need world class talent.
There was so much excitement when they,
he,
he and he answered,
he was coming back and then there was the 20 supposed to fight in the UFC what
supposed to,
and it was talking to the UFC then there was still good but going to Bella toy
and then he was going to make the big announcement and then,
um,
and then,
okay,
and we're going to Japan.
Well I think at least spike TV's going to air the fight.
I think they did something in conjunction with Spike TV for,
for this event.
So I believe,
I don't want to,
I'm pretty sure that it's in conjunction with Spike TV.
Okay.
The fate or,
but who the fuck is he going to fight?
There's no one out there unless Randy coture comes out of retirement and then
then Randy's 50,
whatever years old and you're gonna need,
uh,
a strong undercut to support it as well.
And everybody's signed.
Everyone saw it would be the ability to,
or UFC or it's crazy time or world series of fighting between those three shows.
They have everybody,
me,
Bella toward doesn't even really have a heavyweight champion.
He never see their heavyweight champion fighting.
Who the fuck is there?
Heavyweight
champion.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
I don't think the guy has fun.
I don't think they're heavyweight champion.
He's fought and like two years or something crazy like that.
It's a mass man.
It really is a mess.
It's just this.
It's very unfortunate.
I would like,
you know,
I'd like to see him fight a quality opponent if he's going to come back and get
definitely like the,
like the pri days.
That would have been amazing.
Well,
you know,
they did it before.
Why can't they do it again?
You know?
I mean,
I think it's gotta be,
there's gotta be some upstarts,
some young up and coming fighters out there all over the world that are very
talented.
It's a matter of how having a quality talent scout who really is deep in the
game,
who understands fighting,
who can go out there and recruit those guys at a young age and then have,
well the Japanese also,
there's another angle that must be considered is that the Japanese became big
that the organization's by having pro wrestlers fight in MMA matches like Takada
went to codified Hixon Gracie Hixon Gracie was the man in the fucking Brazilian
Jujitsu world,
right?
And he was the man in the Gracie world.
Like when hoists Gracie was winning the UFC,
he always said,
listen,
my brother is 10 times better than me.
And he always said that.
And then his brother goes and fights for Japan valley to doe and becomes a
superstar in Japan.
And then his brother,
people don't know Hixon fought in the very first pride Hixon fought Takata.
And so when Hickson was fighting in Japan,
Hickson was a superstar to Kata was a pro wrestling superstar.
And that's what made pride takeoff.
And then obviously they were doing these gigantic arena site Tonah super arena
and just a huge fucking venues in New Year's Eve shows.
And
they have to figure out how to rebuild that.
But I don't even think pro wrestling is where it's at in any more in Japan.
I think Japan,
they get fickle.
You know,
these young kids,
they dressed like Elvis,
they dye their hair purple and then next year,
you know,
they become accountants and they know that's the only thing they have like these
weird fabs that get into,
um,
oh,
what's the gentleman that
uh,
gunky pseudo.
Yeah,
he tended to the the singer rocks the robot dancing.
exactly.
Like you're saying what fun day here.
And it may serve as a my tight.
Yeah.
Well his MMA as well.
He was,
yeah,
he was everything very good.
Grab One MMA and all of a sudden he's doing rockstar.
Yeah,
he's there.
He's a character.
He's the main,
he was,
he was a what?
Connie do that,
but that was awesome.
But he's also been in MMA.
He fought,
he,
um,
got him in the heavyweight boxer.
He did the jumping back,
kick off the top rope and then um,
got him in a heel hook.
I bought it and then I'm there.
That was nuts.
And he was outweighed by like,
fuck,
that's crazy.
Lease 150 pounds,
right?
Butter beans gotta be 300 pounds.
Yeah.
Plus madness.
Pure Madden.
And then how do I have the promoter can stay there?
Uh,
I've got a good match.
What are the,
what it was we say,
how do you even justify putting that on?
And then sitting back and going,
I wasn't going to be awesome.
It's just put on a lot of freak shows in Japan.
Let it freak chaise.
That was one of the other things that they did to attract attention.
They had guys that were fighting guys way smaller than him,
you know,
like,
um,
oh the tie there.
I remember the Thai King,
ah,
mighty Mo.
Uh,
fuck.
What's his name?
Cal Clay.
Yes.
Alkali.
Calculated the jumping down,
ran hockey,
and then put the leg back and hitting with the heel and on the way down,
I think he was that way,
but at least 70 killers and least the least mo was all bomber too.
It was a,
that was like,
uh,
[inaudible] we're going to see someone get killed,
but mighty Mo was going to,
uh,
put him in school.
I would fight with his hands down to,
he was like a taekwondo fighter.
It was crazy.
He was fighting them regularly.
He fought out homie and joy from the seven foot,
two blue hair,
one stuff,
and then should have beaten him too.
But,
but they wanted to create him.
They tried to build a man show episode,
become the next k one star.
But in theory,
if you watch the fight,
um,
calculus should have won that one,
the 70,
76 kilo five foot 10 times versus seven foot two Korean beast.
And then landed a head kick to see one of the photos where his legs completely
virtually split.
Yeah.
What happened at k one Max.
They had some wild fights over there.
I remember one Masato was over those and Caitlin for two years,
can Vince Phillips came over the former,
a boxing champion and Pharma sites on a kickboxing fight.
He got his legs destroyed and he fought,
um,
ah,
the handsome MMA guy as well.
He fights for UFC also.
Oh,
what's his name?
Can you please tell me your name and some 60 Yammer.
Oh,
foot 60 [inaudible] mail.
See what happens.
Yeah.
Oh,
how Vince was it Vince?
He fought one of the books or one of the boxes from America.
So he's come over a fight,
MMA,
MMA for the first time,
and then we'll catching a lift together in the hotel.
And I asked him,
I said,
oh,
I say,
what's your game plan?
Have you been doing much MMA?
And he goes,
I'm just going to treat it like a street fight.
Oh,
I'm just gonna.
I'm just gonna Punch that mother fucker in the face.
And once he realizes my power and it's like,
oh,
it's like I gave him a tap on the shoulder and it's like,
Oh,
good luck with that.
And then,
uh,
and then,
and then after the fight we caught the same lift back to the room and I was
mother fucking Japanese set me up,
man.
Day,
new day,
new damn right.
I had no chance in hell and that fight like did you expect,
of course you're going to see.
And then the funny thing was he was talking to Holla at them press conference
and then Francoise both,
not both or no,
no.
He fired both of though.
There was a,
he submitted him and both of was a former boxing champion who fought k one he
came from,
he was an American boxer from,
I believe it was Texas.
He for 60,
I think it was 2005.
Uh Oh fuck it was,
yeah.
So any,
any way?
Um,
yeah,
the press conference is talking all this stuff.
So during the fight there were so many times at the,
the American boxer was given his arm and then he just pushed the,
the way and just rang rain down punches more and more and more.
He wanted to punish him.
I said,
it's happening.
Me It was um,
it was quite,
quite crazy.
He doesn't know who the fuck are was.
I'm looking at his,
um,
his record and I don't see anybody in there that I recognize as a,
uh,
as a book.
So Michael [inaudible],
I don't know who that is.
Yeah.
It was like a special cause it cause it was k one card as well as Kevin Mex card
and they threw in an MMA fight.
They're just for shits and giggles.
K One max.
It was Michael.
Irma.
I don't know who that dude is all,
I don't know.
Well let me Google him real quick cause your American flag beside it.
Yup.
Yeah.
He's a boxer.
Yup.
Visit Page k one.
Yeah,
that's who it was.
That's who it was.
Iron Horse Boxing Club.
Yup.
That's him.
I'm just going to cook reserves.
Yeah.
That uh,
yeah.
And then that they do it all the time.
That also they had a Japanese boxer verse Macedo as well and the same deal as
well.
He didn't learn how to check on the side.
I just went in there and just destroyed his legs.
Masada was an excellent fighter.
He was in a very,
very good,
he's,
um,
uh,
he was the man that every single person wanted to fight because he,
he was the one that was rocking up to the Wayne's in a Ferrari and he was the
Conor Mcgregor of MMA back,
uh,
of,
of Caitlin.
Sorry.
But he wasn't talking.
Was he talking shit,
he didn't have to,
he was doing all these,
he was actually silent.
He was like this,
you mean the condom or Gregg?
I mean,
they were stylish,
ta Nice clothes on sweets.
He was doing the role like commercials and he was driving like the fryer.
He is,
and he was the head,
the hairstyle where you had the blonde tips and every single girl would that
every single a 40,000 seat arena.
And I'm all dressed dressed to pretty much,
and then,
um,
the little golf clubs and there come out this,
the pure excitement of just being in the same room as him.
Who's beautiful man?
He,
um,
he was,
he retired young too.
Yay.
And then once he retired,
k one collapsed probably a year later because they get crazy.
They didn't have this dire anymore without that.
I'm without one.
One fighter.
He was the,
the pinnacle he was,
and I wanted to fight him.
And then every single person,
the one of the fighting,
because a,
if you beat him,
that was going to launch it to the stratosphere of just becoming an overnight,
uh,
phenomenon.
So he fought bull cow,
right?
Yes.
At the same year that I football here,
I fought by book out first in the first fight and then,
um,
it was Masada Bork,
our final and then Bork.
How
should a one after three,
they called it a draw and the Masada,
his eyes closed.
He had a limp.
He is probably,
I think he started urinating blood the next day and they called it an extension
and I draw one more around and Massaro has looked at borecas kind of,
oh no,
this isn't going to be good.
So then I'm bored.
Cows going out there and done the business for another three minutes and then
they've awarded the,
the,
the cow mex title to am book out.
But um,
then the next day you heard,
yeah,
Messiah,
I wasn't healthy.
They should have stopped it,
but because he was Japanese,
I wanted,
they want to give them a chance to win.
Yay.
Wow.
That's not good.
And uh,
kind of like Don,
it's interesting that he never came back,
but,
but that's how I ended up winning the Max twice.
So to his credit,
he's,
um,
he'll be undeniably the,
the greatest depth cause uh,
in the heavyweights they had,
uh,
what,
what was the,
what was the heavyweight champions name?
I'm not changing the heavyweight as Masashi Musashi.
Musashi.
Yeah.
And he never sort of excel to their level where Massaro did save him from Masada
to when the k one twice against legit,
uh,
will kill us.
Um,
yeah,
he's a,
he went,
he was a real world championship caliber and really,
probably the only Japanese have fought at that level.
I think if it wasn't for K,
if it wasn't for side,
there would have been no k one max.
He was him.
He was the kid that shine that said,
yeah,
we need to make this 70 kilo division because I'm,
this kid is going to take us all away and put us on the wall stage,
legitimate,
um,
as a country.
So it's unique in combat sports that he decided to stay retired.
Yes.
You know,
I want an a wonder what that was was just probably the punishment from some of
those fights just got to a point where money,
the fame,
I think you've got to the stage where he'd,
he'd already conquered the sport and there was,
there was nowhere for him to go anymore.
He'd already done everything and had money in the bank.
And then I think get the stage where you don't want to wake up at six in the
morning anymore.
You don't want to have to put ice on your knees and Yay and your shoulders after
every session.
Um,
so yeah,
everybody that fights in MMA or kickboxing,
there's always that one person in every sport that has that life,
whether it's Ronda Rousey in women's MMA,
you know,
and then the other girls are looking at her and they,
they're,
they're struggling or whether it's Masato or whether it's Conor McGregor.
There's like this one person.
Yes.
One is,
these are a few outliers.
It sort of figure it out.
And then Holly Holmes even coming out and said,
um,
I want what Rhonda has.
I wanted what Massada had.
Oh,
I would love the,
to robbery doing the pull.
I remember one commercial,
he's in a Fri,
he pulls up,
you see that pull up in the door.
I've been like a space ship.
And then they're focusing on his role at the watch and it's like,
and he's in a suit and he's looking stylish and he's got it.
Yeah.
He's got,
uh,
just,
just the king.
It's like a look at this guy.
This is what a,
what a hero.
Sorry.
And as a cause you're get by playing the same game.
It's like,
how come I can't be him?
I'd love to be him.
That'd be so cool.
Did the guys and k one
the heavyweight division k one,
um,
did there those guys make good money?
Uh,
well they'd had a eight men tournament once a year and when it was at its peak,
they had the Tokyo Dome,
90,000 people in it.
It would sell it in two hours.
Uh,
and,
and then you'd have to fight three times in,
in approximately three hours in the grand prize was a 500,000 us.
So do you know how much profit they must've made of you have 90,000 people in an
arena and you're selling those,
you know,
just think about it.
Even if it's only 10 bucks.
Yeah.
That is a fuck load of money and that is a goddamn fuck load of money and you're
only paying out 500 grand to the winter end.
You have paper view and miss the issue might have forgot to pay tax or for a few
years in a row.
Then he had to do,
I think he believed he had to do a little bit of,
um,
time.
Uh,
Nah,
he got,
we stay at home,
home,
home detention.
That's it.
They home attention for a few years.
Oh,
that's great.
And that's when
it's better than jail man.
Uh,
but yeah,
and then,
uh,
the other gentleman took care of the k one and that's when,
that's when the size shows that it happened.
That's when the Bob Sapp started coming along.
Main choice that are coming in.
Oh,
is that what happened?
That's when
she had this platform where everything was 90,000 people and then everything was
perfect.
And then,
um,
gay and then a sort of sat a declining from that moment on as too bad because in
the glory days of k one,
you know,
back in the Ernesto who stays Peter Arts,
God,
Mike Bernardo is like,
those fights were so technical,
so high level,
so great.
Jerome Le Banner,
I mean those,
all,
my God,
we had same Greco,
eh,
that was fighting for Australia.
He was the Australian hero.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
it was semi Schiltz and Oh,
before,
this is before the shoot.
And it was before the golden era,
Larry Smith.
Um,
and it just seemed to be those eight guys that were just keep knocking each
other out a year after year after year for about 10 years in a row.
And as a teenager there was,
there was just the,
some of them would get a VHS of the latest Graham pricks and then you sit there
and watch it and then we,
so uh,
yeah,
you could've moved.
You'd,
yeah.
All the boys are sitting around with the popcorn member Andy Hook and the hook
was an undersized guy.
Andy Hug.
Remember those days?
Yeah.
The Spinning,
the spinning heel kicks to the thighs.
Yeah.
We'll kick to the thigh.
Yes.
Nobody was doing that.
You know who is doing that?
Well,
he was a killer cushion.
Right.
Here's corrugation.
Yes.
Same as same Greco and a lot of wild kids send me,
she'll send me,
she sent me,
she'll,
it'll be the same recur Andy Hug and they all had that coalition.
Um,
yeah,
just that mentality of walk forward through leaks.
But Andy Hook was only like five,
10 or something like that.
Right.
It wasn't a big guy and he had to put on a lot of muscle in order to fight those
heavyweights.
Very undersized.
But you see him fight?
Yes.
A lot of those guys in that division and um,
it would,
yeah.
Today
or knock you out and then a month later I would knock them out and then it was
just crazy that they fought like that.
Yeah.
Everyone would fight each other six,
seven,
eight times and it'd be a 50,
50 split.
You know,
who was ever on that day was going to win and whoever didn't get knocked out and
training whoever who got knocked out like the furthest amount of time from that
tournament.
Yes.
Because those guys were just destroying their chins.
If you think about it,
I mean,
how could you get knocked out and they get knocked out again a month later.
That's fucking crazy.
The mock Hunt's back when he was a human race,
if was standing tonitto dropping their hands,
let needs taking,
taking pot shots at each other's Chin and just standing there and smiling and
then another rally.
It was a,
yeah,
that's the sort of stuff that had made a legends and that was when Mirko Mirko
Cro cop start first start fighting came when he was so skinny.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
There was,
I guess he wasn't lifting weights or anything back then,
maybe,
or just wasn't as much or,
and then he had to put on weight as well.
[inaudible]
was always the bridesmaid always doing the business.
And then when it always came to the,
the eight man,
he'd never quite successfully in the toes get close.
You remember when he,
uh,
he fought,
he almost won,
but he broke his arm against hoost.
Ooh.
Shattered is a shattered his form.
You'll fuck,
man.
Those were some amazing,
amazing fights.
And again,
that's something that a lot of Americans just never experienced this.
It didn't air over here before the UFC era came.
That was the pinnacle.
That was the combat that was combat sports.
Pretty much it was before the UFC because it was before pride.
It was before the UFC.
That was the big martial arts event was the k one Grand Prix.
Yes.
When you,
when you get that big trophy in the fucking confetti in the sky and the giant
check,
you know what I mean with that shit.
I'm a giant checks.
Yes.
Where the giant checks go.
I've got a giant check.
I would like to see a giant check come back.
I'll go,
I'll go to a million but joint and chick.
Oh Wow.
My Gym when I'm quite proud of from Thailand,
from Thailand and say wow that looks good.
Yeah.
It looks close.
Zero.
Someone says how much does it not?
They're not dead,
but that doesn't matter.
It's not zero
and its entire so you're missing the point on it's not about money.
It's about giant checks.
Yes.
The back in the,
yeah Kaylen was cool.
It's a,
but you think of k one the only paying out 500 grand to the winner.
Yes.
Fuck man.
That's a lot of money.
They're making it 90,000 seats so I dunno.
I Dunno if 90,000 times 10 is that nine million ninety million?
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
right.
Okay.
So it's more than 10 for the gate though.
Like what's the gate?
It's usually,
I don't know,
2030 40 bucks a ticket plus concessions and parking and all that extra.
Right.
So 90,000 times 10 is only 900,000 but it's way more than 10 bucks a ticket.
Right?
Yeah.
Your boy,
which is a $9 million gate,
but then ring size,
probably way more than a hundred bucks.
Like ring,
ring side of the UFC could be as much as like 500 bucks,
maybe even more.
Right?
Oh for sure.
Like a big boxing match.
I know that,
well,
a lot of his like scalpers too,
right?
You never know.
Mgm I paid to which a joyous babe Bavis Hendrickson.
I paid $500 and I was,
oh,
is that in the bleaches?
My,
my mind knows actually bled.
That's how high up I was.
Who knows actually blood.
Yeah,
I have a feeling that was because you probably got punched in that fairly
recently.
I bet.
If my nose is up there,
it wouldn't have black.
The oxygen levels are so low.
That A,
is that a getting dizzy?
That's ridiculous.
Who the fuck gets a nose bleed on a mountain?
Is it shit real?
You get nose bleeds when you go to a mountain.
Uh,
I'll get nosebleeds.
You get a nosebleed on a plane and I,
well it's
pressure cabin.
Right?
That makes sense.
But I never heard of anybody getting a nose bleed in the nose when you jumped
out of a plane.
He didn't get nose bleeds.
Really?
When you pass your,
maybe you bro.
I'll me bro.
Well you didn't know me then man.
I would have hooked you up with better seats.
That's ridiculous.
It's such an important fight.
You want to be close.
I think I told you last time the lady bought me my,
my ticket for free to go and be part of the cause I wasn't going to go at all.
And then the lady bought my ticket,
but then I bought the ticket there.
Watch the fight say is.
Yeah.
But anyway,
anyway,
it was,
um,
fights are so interesting live because you get this energy from being there in
that arena that you can't reproduce it watching it at home.
And I don't think people that see it at home,
we'll ever truly know what it's like to see a live fight.
Because also there's something that gets like,
I remember the first time I went to see a boxing match,
I remember thinking like,
Oh,
there's no commentary.
This is weird.
Like there's something that sterilizes it a little bit about hearing Jim Lampley
here,
ABC wide world of sports or whatever the fuck it was back in the day when I was
watching boxing.
And then to go see a boxing match live,
you're like,
well,
there's no one talking.
You know,
you just hearing thump,
thump,
Bang.
You know,
you've seen someone like I was there when Mickey Bork,
um,
Mickey Rourke,
Mickey work,
Micky Ward rather confusing people.
Mickey a ward was coming up in Lowell,
Massachusetts before we ever had those crazy fights.
A series of fights with a turtle.
Got It.
Yep.
I saw him fight when he was a real young professional and we saw him fight a in
Lowell,
me and my buddy Jimmy lawless and went to see him fight live.
It was just like being there in,
in a small arena who,
you know,
with a local hometown guy and see a local boxing match and hear the slap of
leather on faces and bodies.
It's a such a different experience than watching it on television,
which is like so much more.
Um,
it seems like it's not really happening,
even if it's happening,
even if it's brutal,
you're not there,
you know?
Um,
same with that liquid promotion that I'm doing now with my wife and I live with
the CMT.
You've,
you're feeling empty,
meaning cage more time.
Say,
say you feel,
you feel why in
the in the room.
Yeah.
It not only watching it,
but um,
you punching as someone's getting hit Ya,
Ya.
Yeah.
Um,
here's wrapping the,
and your body and backing your neck.
Yeah,
you got goosebumps.
You can't not look away from the cage because at any given second someone's
going to get knocked out.
So,
but you don't have that when you're watching on TV.
You're looking at your phone,
you're looking up,
you're looking down.
But why are they alive?
Um,
yeah.
You can feel the atmosphere.
You can smell it and you can smell the toil you can use.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's a different beast than when you're,
um,
when,
when you present the tight oil or the lineament yeah.
What does that should do?
Shouldn't do anything.
Yeah.
It warms you up.
It's nice and warm.
So,
yeah.
Your measures in the skin so that you're nice and loose and when you're shadow
boxing,
you're,
your body's on fire.
So you feel a,
instead of skipping for 10 minutes,
you put the tile and you rub it in and then you're already warm.
My friend has a doctor told me,
listen man,
if that shit did anything,
it would get into your muscles itself and you'd be poisoned.
Really?
I go,
really?
He goes,
yeah.
It's called a topical analgesic and heat up.
Your skin doesn't do a damn thing.
Yeah.
If you really,
if you,
if you've got a light sweat and you put that stuff on,
you want a urine fire it,
you're going to try and put yourself under a hose.
Let me ask you this,
if that's the case,
how can you put that stuff on your skin and then you're clenching and if you're
clenching,
that stuff can get in someone's eyes.
No,
maybe
it does,
but you massage it in 15 minutes before you walked.
Right?
So if you're grabbing and you're fighting for the plum,
yeah,
right.
And you've got that shit on your forearms and it's got a turning away and it
gets in his eyes is that happened to you?
But at the time you get onto the ring gear,
it's absorbed.
So in all that,
that's why he can't use it in the UFC.
UFC in the early days,
man,
Dude's,
which is goals and we can put Vaseline 11 I buddies,
well between the,
the limit and the Vaseline all over say,
yeah,
you're come out and yeah,
and you're shining and you're glossy and yeah,
we catch in the kicks and can pull out of the catches.
And the only thing is if you're the last fight of the night,
say if you teach someone in the stomach and then you put your foot on the canvas
and then if you get oil all the time,
you know,
the last fight,
the canvas is just the ice skating rink.
It's terrible.
And then,
and if you've got logos on the canvas as well,
Vaseline and the stickers and then,
yeah,
it's,
it's a complete nightmare.
Well that's a,
that was a nightmare in MMA for a while that they would have all these ads on
the octagon and they would spray these ads down with,
you know,
spray paint essentially or like,
um,
uh,
like an iron on.
And it would be,
it wouldn't absorb like canvas,
like cam for people don't know canvas.
When you get it wet,
actually you get more traction.
It's actually kind of Nice,
which is why when you watch MMA fight,
sometimes you see guys pour water on the ground and then they'll move their feet
on the water because maybe their skin is dry and they want to get their skin
nice and moist.
And it actually gives you like a little traction.
A dry canvas sometimes can be slippery,
especially a fresh canvas.
Yes.
But those fucking logos of the worst,
especially those things are terrible.
It's because in that painting on this,
even if there stickers that vinyl,
because it doesn't absorb any moisture.
So the moisture sits on.
If you step on it,
a whip and then you're scared to throwing kicks.
So for our kicker,
who's doesn't want to go to the ground?
Oh,
it's a nightmare.
It's a mess.
Then you're,
you're one of your biggest weapons has been removed.
It's is good if you're got lazier because then you can watch one canvas.
And then what's your opponent?
The same.
He's joking.
You can't do that if you have a lazy eye.
Right.
What the fuck do you have to pick?
Which I looked through did.
Um,
I used to have a girlfriend,
had a lazy boy.
Oh,
how dare you.
Uh,
jokes coming.
I had to get rid of her because she was seeing other people.
I knew that joke.
He fucking got me with it.
Anyways,
it's kind of a bitch.
How dare you?
I knew that one common,
I knew that joke,
but I knew a job.
First of all,
I knew a joke was coming cause you had a,
here's a joke coming up in your face and I heard that one but I forgot it.
Fucking marijuana
long term memory got me.
Damn.
I got to try and keep my brain in tech so I can try and be funny like you.
That's one.
Another thing on longevity in this sport.
Well your brain's amazingly intact for 120 fights.
That's incredible.
You've taught most people,
what's the guy going to be like 39 years old?
He was 120 fights off.
Fucking God can't even wipe his own ass.
You gotta hire people to do that.
Okay,
you're fine.
But what do you think that that is?
Just a,
because of all that sparring as well,
that,
that um,
you know,
very technical what we call playing,
where he'd just tapping each other and not hard,
you know,
Ramon Decker,
Dutch style fighting in the gym every day.
But instead,
just so we're working on technique work,
well I'll put a different tech,
different um,
theories with boxes.
For instance,
boxes we'll spar for twice a week,
three times a week leading up to a fight for 10 weeks.
And then their brain damage is caused from the sparring and not actually fight,
but the actual preparation and then times that by a 30,
40 flights.
What,
how many fighters have more than 40 fights in boxing?
So,
so I don't know.
I've been hit with a lot of hot shorts.
We,
a lot of people say how come a normal person would be knocked out and you
didn't,
I guess it's just just luck.
I have nothing but luck to you have a good chin.
Yeah.
Lucky that is not,
uh,
not uh,
goaling yet.
Um,
yeah.
Good Chin is really for,
you know,
cause my whack me.
Huh?
He certainly,
he didn't miss,
he got me multiple times with the flying knee man.
Yeah.
One flying knee was at the second round and he caught you with that.
Um,
I don't remember what round it was.
Second or third round.
He,
he would have flying knee.
But you know,
never had you heard,
never had you down.
Never had you wobbly.
Yeah,
cuts hurt.
But at the same time I knew there was no,
there wasn't one point in the flight where I thought all kind of go in and it's
like nine,
nine.
Every time he hit me hard,
it was more so I've got to get it back.
And there's a difference between the,
the phrase had you heard and hurt
like a,
people listen to that.
And I go,
well,
of course he got hurt.
He got hit.
He got,
you already said he had all these stitches.
When someone says in the fighting world,
he was hurt and means his body is not functioning right.
You got whacked and all sudden you see your legs go rubber or you see a guy
cover up maybe to a liver shot and you realize he's hurt.
He's hurt,
doesn't have a window near the point where I thought if I get hit one more time,
I'm going to go down.
There is no point whatsoever during the flight that I was getting hit at the
same time I,
there was never a moment where I thought,
I can't not win this fight until that bill rent.
And it's like,
okay,
now I'm at a time when you watched the fight and the replay did that fourth
round incident when you cracked him with that punch and he started cleaning his
feet.
The,
that drives me fucking nuts.
I haven't watched the fight yet.
Oh,
say disappointed in myself to be very angry.
When you watch that fourth round,
you're going to carry out the dude,
the courage up to watch it because I'm still,
I'm still trying to get over it.
That and it's,
it's,
it's heartbreaking when you lose man.
It sucks.
I can only imagine.
So invested that 10 weeks and then all you want and I can taste it.
I want it.
I can feel the belt around my waist.
So I want to,
and then when the decision comes and they raise up,
position his hand and it's just,
it's a heartbreaking.
And then,
and then look at people's faces that um,
believed in you as well.
Like hands with them.
He came on board with one.
So just before this fight come up and say,
yeah,
again,
I've got to thank them for coming on board as a whole,
but monster energy drain once that like Ted for them,
this funds or wait till I go.
Like I said,
I want to,
I want to wind it to be for them.
They'd be proud to have their logo on my shorts and then when you lose,
I've got to look at hands and the face and,
and thinking,
fuck me,
I'm sorry I let you down.
Listen man,
you didn't let anybody down.
You fought a great fight against it and a world class fighter.
I mean Cosmo,
Xander is a bad motherfucker.
You fought a great fight,
but you know,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
it's so many people.
And then,
and then my little girl,
she's 12 years old,
she's sitting in front row and then,
uh,
my wife said,
oh yeah,
she was in tears because when dead,
she's just saying that winning.
So when dad's not,
not only did he lose,
but he's caught up and he's limping and he's um,
broken.
It's um,
it sucks.
Yeah.
But it doesn't,
it doesn't diminish your enthusiasm for wanting to compete.
Yeah.
He,
oh,
I'm kind of waiting.
I'm fighting Siris and the 5th of December,
so,
so once,
once my foot sealed,
I'll get back to Australia,
I'll get back on the road.
It's the back on the pads and the,
and now I'm more determined to make up for this lofts are why.
And I make sure that I'm not only gonna beat saw it,
um,
but I have to go out there and destroy him.
Tim,
get back my credibility is one of the top guys.
Are you still fighting that black dynamite do this?
Yes.
Source.
That's his name is full name.
So as Washington source.
Cyrus Cyrus.
Okay.
That's where I got confused.
Yeah.
You were saying Saurus s O.
R.
O.
S.
I was like,
who the fuck is that?
But Cyrus Wa Goddamn Australian accent.
Yes.
Iris Washington is a,
he's a wild days.
If you were in my country,
you don't have good point.
Yes.
The country being a country next month say,
yeah.
Say sorry in the cage and the cage.
MMA gloves.
Moitai rules.
That's a pain killer too.
He's another killer.
He's a,
he's,
he's exactly like the gentleman you were saying from glory with the,
the,
the Daniel.
The spinning kicks in.
The hook kicks in a the crazy style and the,
but he's more adapted to more time Cyrus House.
Yes.
You know,
he's,
he's a wild,
got a watch my,
he does a lot of crazy shit.
A lot of spinning back kick to the body.
I put a highlight reel of his on Facebook the other day and the amount of people
that watch the,
I'm just like,
what are you doing?
[inaudible] and suppose cause he's good.
I why?
Why don't,
why don't want to find him?
Because he's awesome.
He's going to bring such an entertaining fight for the Australian crowd that
they,
they're going to be crazy if they don't come along and watch it because it's
going to be madness.
Yeah.
He's,
he's an interesting guy and um,
he's a black belt in taekwondo as well as being very proficient at Moitai at a
world class level.
And combining those two things together is very interesting.
It's like we're talking to the knuckle boxing as well.
He's,
he's fighting with headbutts bare knuckle boxing with headbutts.
Oh,
where's he doing that?
Uh,
either Cambodia.
yeah.
So what happens when you get hurt and you've got to go to the hospital in
Cambodia,
they just give you your own chicken,
do your own food.
They give you a ball,
a ball of yarn and fish hook cause stitch yourself together.
Bitch,
we're done.
Oh fuck man.
I say say hopefully he doesn't have his natural instinct that's trying to hit
button in the clinch.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Right.
How many fights does he do like that?
Uh,
from,
from his Facebook record that I,
that I shared when I,
when the,
when the match first got made,
um,
he was like 70,
with 50 wins,
47 knockouts.
So Jesus,
I believe he said a few more fights in that he said,
oh,
that's actually my older record album and it's actually a listener.
But when I got off his Facebook and then people go and what,
you're 39,
uh,
you're not in your prime anymore.
Why would you fight someone so dangerous for us?
Because I want to give the Australian public in the fans flights that you're
going to not want to miss.
When people say that you know your prime no,
you still fight like you're in your prime.
I feel like a number.
You're not fighting like,
uh,
like when I watched you fight,
I'm watching you fight cosmo.
Who's a big strong guy and you're not fighting like a guy who was over the hill.
You're fighting like a cautious smart veteran who's facing a very dangerous fast
guy and you far very well.
It wasn't,
it wasn't like a fire like,
oh man,
this guy's lost a step.
It wasn't like that man,
you know,
I'm,
I'm an honest dude.
If I see someone losing a step,
it makes me very concerned because that,
trying to pretend that that didn't happen.
It's super dangerous.
I don't see that with,
the only time that I feel old is when someone asks me because in the gym I feel
like I'm still 25,
but when someone says,
how are Ya?
And then when I leave,
when I hear the word lead my lips and I say 39,
it's like,
fuck.
That's to attribute that to consistency or,
I mean,
you very clean with your diet.
Like what is it?
I,
I had and I,
he just,
um,
what's your diet like?
Uh,
it's okay.
my wife's,
um,
uh,
half Mexican American,
so she cooked of Tacos,
Tacos,
I,
lots of Thai food.
What's to Asian?
Lots of Japanese.
We,
uh,
to avoid anything.
Like,
do you avoid sugar or alcohol or uh,
uh,
OPM,
heroin?
No,
I stay away from those.
Especially like
try,
I try while they're very compelling a year but not evidence I hamburgers,
I'm,
I can't say that I'm a saint.
I'm definitely,
but I don't drink,
I don't really,
I'm lucky to have five busy year,
so I stay off there.
That'll help.
That'll help a lot.
That has longevity.
You get like,
um,
uh,
hopeful when you see garlic Bernard Hopkins fucking 50 years old.
I do.
He's probably that guy.
And then also,
uh,
lucky you were saying before,
Randy couture,
he's also a gentleman that is proving that you can still fight with the guys
that are in their late twenties,
early thirties.
Yeah.
He won a world championship level deep into his forties.
Yay.
And then again,
another gentleman that can put a conversation together that's heading up all
these flights in Bernal Hopkins.
Uh,
again,
uh,
it's just,
yeah,
Randy is completely lucid.
He's talking to him,
he's articulate.
He's a gentleman entrepreneur.
He's,
he's,
and he's not silly.
He is making,
he's making money from a different avenues.
So I saw him hitting the pounds the other day.
He was working out with Jay Glazer scenario war does the NFL for Fox and you
know,
Jay was holding the pads form and Randy was hitting them and I was like,
I wonder what the fuck he's doing.
I wonder if he sees fade orange.
He's like,
you know,
US and man,
I'll fucking take that one big fight.
Cause Shit,
he could probably make a shit load of money.
Even Shane Mosley,
Shane Mosley.
Um,
but Randy might still be under contract.
He might still have like some UFC contract thing going on and mom didn't,
Dana expelling from UFC where he's not allowed to enter the arena is anymore or
something.
I don't know.
How do you do that?
Like I can do whatever the fuck you want if I'm wrong,
you know,
so Randy coture go,
go fight your mom.
I'll give a shit.
You always get ringside seats.
You know,
that's captain America.
I Dunno.
I don't know if he did come back.
It would be weird because he's,
he's been off for a long time and the last time he fought I believe was in
Toronto at the Rogers arena and he got chumping front kicked in the face by Leo
Machida knocked out.
And the Cheetah,
that was the famous tags Stephen's ago.
That was the first time that anyone has ever won by a friend kick to the face
since Steven Seagal and vented it.
Well,
jumping front,
jumping phase,
jumping Anderson had won
by a front kick to the face before.
I apologize.
It was this,
that was the Stephen as he goes.
Have you ever tried a jumping front kick to the face in a Muay Thai fight?
Jumping Frankie?
No,
but I,
I landed a friend,
uh,
I,
I used to try and land one frank kick to the face every fight as like a,
as a,
as a trademark thing back when I was in my early.
Really?
Yeah.
That was my,
that was my thing to try lane when I actually,
actually,
my wife,
uh,
she was known as a German June.
Now John,
John,
hang on,
hang on.
What is it?
So her,
her Thai name translated was the beautiful face.
Beautiful Frankie.
Keep face the beautiful,
beautiful friend.
Keep face a face.
Teamplay that sounds cooler and time.
How do you in Thai,
John,
John [inaudible] Nah,
Nah.
[inaudible] her thing was,
I'm so much better than beautiful front kick facer
and then uh,
she broke a couple of girls noses with them at the heel striking down those and
uh,
yeah,
she,
she's,
she was um,
she's awesome.
My wife's really amazing fighting.
It's interesting because it ties,
use the teeth to the face almost like the flat part of the foot more and almost
like a push kick.
Yes.
I like to push you back.
Very rarely would you see someone getting actually knocked out from it that you
can see the head gets snapped but you wouldn't see actually getting knocked out.
And so they don't throw it like a karate style front kick night,
like a say like a semi shot.
Always used to throw it to the body.
He would throw it like a,
like a,
a thrust Kik,
different style of kicking.
Why the tires never threw it like that?
Because obviously when you're watch Anderson versus [inaudible],
it's the same kick.
It's just done with a slightly different style and it's very effective.
Yeah,
it was weird.
It was,
it was nuts.
And then a foreman shaded a to replicate that same kick not long later on.
It was like damn these things.
That's pretty cool and never see it again.
I mean you see guys attempt it but there's not been a single knockout.
And Justin Buckholtz got a knockout I think in ring of fire.
I think that's where he fought,
which is um,
uh,
an organism.
Sven beans organization in Colorado.
I think that's where Justin,
he's one of the um,
Alpha Male,
uh,
Uriah Faber's camp,
one of the trainers there and one of the fighters.
I can really think he's a fight this weekend.
He might have fun this weekend.
Um,
but you very rarely see guys knock guys out with it these days.
Like it was those two fights.
Justin's fight and I can't remember a,
another knockout since in the UFC.
People try it,
but it hasn't been a,
it been utilized,
uh,
as effectively.
What do you got there for me?
Ah,
there you are.
John Wayne par,
cosmo,
Xander,
Bam,
Tay.
Front kick to the face.
Hey,
what is that?
That thing that they always do and when people throw kicks in,
I'm in Australia.
Well at a high five to the face with your foot.
Oh,
okay.
That's a little awkward.
Trying to make something a little more eloquent.
Come up with a better name.
Monster must like that though.
You go highlighted the m on your shorts.
Perfect.
That's a perfect picture for the wall.
Oh is,
I'm quite happy that cosmo was quite enough to stand there for,
for me.
For the,
for the photo shoot to let me execute the,
Frankie did that one very nice about what a gentleman he is.
What a gentlemen Instagram later on.
So everyone in get out.
So your fight for Cage Moy,
Tai,
um,
you guys are using the small gloves and using the mortar gloss.
Is it,
are you the only organization that has a full striking with more with Moitai
rules but with a MMA gloves?
I believe so.
And then a gentleman,
uh,
Martin Hogben,
a Hogan Hogan in,
um,
uh,
island.
He's,
he's seen my promotion.
Then he started it as well.
And then he's had done three shows so far in Ireland and his last show,
Conor McGregor.
And uh,
what's the other gentleman from Iceland that,
uh,
that flight's going to?
Nelson,
Ghana,
Ghana was there as well.
Nobody in the crowd.
And I think that both blown away by the,
the adrenaline of the cage because it's so exciting and it's so fast and there's
no ground and then there's no action on the fence.
I'm within five seconds.
It's broken up.
So it's just continuous violence.
So do you like the breaking it up though with the clench?
Because in my tie,
you know,
in real Moitai they don't break it up.
Uh,
if there's an election,
so if you're throwing knees and it becomes a stalemate within two or three
seconds,
if there's no action that they break it straight away.
Whereas if there's no actual or is in a MMA,
you can press something and gets the free hold onto them and hold,
hold,
hold.
On.
The UFC,
they usually will stop it and the separate eventually.
I honestly believe that especially in MMA since grappling such an integral part
of mixed martial arts,
I don't think they should ever break things up.
I think if a guy's got you down and he's just holding you down,
that's tough shit.
You got to figure out how to get up.
I don't think it should score very well for the guy on top,
but I really don't.
I don't believe in stand ups cause I feel like especially for a striker,
right,
you have five minutes and every round starts standing up.
Everyone starts with your advantage.
No round starts on the ground.
You'd never start where like okay this round John,
you're on top.
You know you started on top cause he was like,
no.
But every round starts standing up and that's the advantage of the striker.
This,
the grappler has to figure out how to get ahold of them,
how to get them to the ground.
I think once you've done that,
it's the guy on the grounds business.
Try to get back up.
It's fucking boring.
You're good.
You like,
we're fucking guys,
Bro.
I'm just saying there's only five minutes.
Okay,
and for grappling,
five minutes is not that long.
You,
if you,
if he say,
if you were grappling with another guy who was also at your level in grappling
and you guys were tangling for five minutes,
if you're both at the same level is going to be a lot of stalemates and it takes
little incremental improvements and advances for you to get to a position where
you finally get to a mount or you finally get an Armbar,
you finally get a choke.
It's hard to do and you can't do it if you keep standing people up when they
stale mate,
because that's stalemates apart of grappling.
It's like it's your job to figure out if you're on the bottom,
how to get up or how to submit him from your back.
It's the guy's job on the top to hold you down and to figure out how to get you
in a better position and to dominate you and to figure out how to submit you.
But son of time,
five minutes is not enough time.
Yeah.
The same with the pressed against the fence when sometimes then they stuck there
for for more than two minutes.
And when the guys get impatient than they make mistakes.
Like if a guy's pressing you up against the cage and he's knee and your legs and
he's hitting,
he was short elbows and you're just waiting for the referees to separate.
If the referee doesn't separate,
you might do something silly,
you might make a mistake,
you might.
And that's what they're trying to do.
Like Randy coture was the master at that,
at a holding guys up against the cage,
but he didn't get it.
They didn't separate him very often because he was constantly moving.
He'd be constantly punching.
You constantly need your body needing your legs.
He was working you and he was pushing on you and wearing you out.
That was a big part of his strategy and I just feel like,
um,
you know with MMA they're trying really hard to make it more fan friendly and
they're trying really hard to make the action like more exciting to watch.
But I think in doing so your water down the art a little bit and there's an art
with two guys trying to figure out what to do to each other to,
to defend and to attack and figure out who can win.
Yep.
I don't know,
that's just my feeling.
But I think if you're going to have pure stand up,
just pure stand up striking,
I think what you're doing is the best way to do it.
I think small gloves and I think doing it in a cage and where,
you know,
you don't have to worry about guys falling through the ropes.
Like I've seen that in a lot of events,
especially when guys start clenching and they get up against the rope and maybe
their buck goes through like two ropes.
They slid back or maybe the duck and away from a punch and they wind up falling
out of the ropes.
It happens too much.
Yeah,
I've seen 'em how's it a,
a local,
uh,
my two I show in the ring and the head,
two gentlemen Clinton away and the other guys,
uh,
the full on straight through the center.
And then they had the judges' table right beside the ring and they had all the
trophies lined up and it was those trophies where the angel was on top of the
trophy with the hands clasped together.
And it was a,
it was,
uh,
like raises and the guy's head miss the trophy by,
by inches and it flopped onto the desk.
And if it had been a little bit to the left,
he would add piece straight threes.
I would have been detrimental for fuck would they have sharp objects right next
to the rings.
Hey guys are throwing each other around town would have been horrific.
It was definitely seeking say,
oh,
always made sure with Ashley's now I trophies or under the table,
but that was a learning curve.
Bernard Hopkins,
well known,
he didn't fall,
he fell and broke my shoulder.
Um,
but within the cage,
um,
from a personal experience,
I've had a and s
18,
19 fights in the ring,
but to be locked in that cage,
it as a,
not as a spectator,
but as a fighter,
it's such a different atmosphere in a different arena.
Um,
it definitely brings out a completely different beast.
And then when you know your opponents were,
and those little gloves,
um,
yeah,
every single sensor in your bodies is tingling because you know,
if you make a mistake you're going to be completely dominated or wiped out or
uh,
not the end knocked unconscious or it's about bare knuckle ban a whole,
I haven't tried it in um,
sounds very painful.
And then cause my hands too,
I think the idea of smacking someone in the forehead with being a who wouldn't
be healthy for my longevity.
So I like the idea with having him reps and having the small gloves and having
the quick cause with my mom,
a CMC gloves,
uh,
it's half,
half padding,
half Joe,
so it's in,
it's almost a six ounce instead of a four.
So it's not like a complete them,
but it's still fingerless you design them.
I had them talked with a company in Australia.
They helped design it and make them pick up because I work as a promoter.
I didn't want to have someone dying on my show.
So I made a,
I made it a thicker padding because there's no taking down.
There's no holding.
It's just a complete trauma for four or five rounds.
So,
um,
well the argument is,
I mean I see what your point is,
but the argument is that,
you know,
you're saying you wouldn't want to break your hands on someone's forehead.
The argument is that you could throw it Shin kick with full power.
So Shin,
which is much more powerful than a punch Shin to the head,
right knee to the head,
elbows to the head.
Yes.
Why do you allow someone to tape up their wrist and form an unnatural bond?
Right?
And then tape up their hands and make it nice and hard so he can punch full
blast.
Whereas the reality is the hands should be used judiciously because there's not
a lot of room for error.
If you do make a mistake and you punched full blast and you hit someone in an
elbow,
they cover up like that and your knuckle slamming in the elbow,
you might shatter your hand.
You might shatter your hand on their forehead,
you might shatter your in your hand a lot of different ways and you have to be
way more clean with your strikes and it makes it more realistic and they think a
lot of people think that that would actually alleviate a lot of the brain
damage.
Okay.
What do you,
what do you think of that?
Ah,
yeah,
just the way my hands are always sorta.
I've had a little bit of difficulties in the past with them,
so that's nice.
That's nice.
It's reassuring.
When I had the hammer it was on that,
that's keeping my wrist into a,
a noise from a place.
So when I,
when I punch wrong that I'm just not going to break my hand.
Okay.
But it just having that cushioning at the top of the knuckles because the
knuckles are so sensitive that,
um,
I've broken them before so,
uh,
it,
it just,
and I know why my hands are wrapped properly,
then I can hit it with full force and not have any repercussions.
Does that argument make sense to you?
That it does?
It does,
but I think it'd be more open hearted.
Open hand slaps us Rutan and that time Chris,
yes he stole was pretty
insane.
The Ida,
the you definitely,
you wouldn't want to punch with their clothes.
Fishy.
Definitely be one of the arm to the body.
Maybe you would right hire five someone's face with your palm and then you have
a lot of high pokes and so that's a real issue with MMA.
Yes.
Even when cmts had haven't few punches will.
So yeah man,
I wish they figured something out to fix that drives me nicely.
Danger.
What I'm doing with the CMT gloves is a,
with the fingerless because they had a lot of people were saying,
well why are you doing it?
There's so many problems with the UFC and the police.
Where do you want to bring that same element into the what you're doing with the
cage,
but at the same time if you wear boxing gloves in the in the cage,
it just looks,
looks so dumb.
It looks,
it does because you had your spent every single weekend watching UFC and then
you're trying to get the same respect from the MMA fans for what you're doing
and what we're in the w with Kate most high rules and you've got these big
pillows on yet the UFC guys were in the thing,
those ones or is it possible that you could do something that's not fingerless
but it's also very light that it looks like a bad glove?
You know,
it's the visual.
I think it's the visual that cells and and uh,
as a fighter as well.
I know when I put them on I feel like I'm a warrior.
It's a weird thing to try and explain,
but it's just,
um,
I know that when I close my fist and I,
and then when I clench,
I know that I have my fingers and I can catch the,
the kicks a lot it and manipulate the guard so I can throw elbows easier as
well.
So it's um,
you also read a different element of finding.
I've,
I've had so many fights,
gloves and then you put these little things on and then the bell rings and then
I feel,
I feel free because when I'm training,
I trained for 10 weeks with no gloves.
When I'm clinching,
I train when I play spar with the kicks and then when all of a sudden I'm a
strictly,
when I put boxing gloves on and then I'm not,
I can't execute the same game plan when I'm training to win on fighting if it,
does that make sense?
It doesn't make sense,
but why wouldn't you just train with the gloves,
the boxing gloves,
uh,
in,
in the,
in the cage,
in the cages.
Just,
um,
I see your point.
You're not looking right.
Yeah.
I want,
I want the MMA people to look at my promotion and say,
yeah,
fuck yeah,
that's cool.
It's wall.
It's everything that they want out of MMA.
Yes.
That especially people that don't like the ground game,
it's everything they want.
Wild,
crazy.
Still not going to get their respect.
If I wear boxing gloves,
I need to make it this,
the same environment with everything the same,
just eliminate the ground.
So there was strikers have a,
a platform node to fight in that same arena because of so many gods.
So I get so many emails from people that want to fight on the show because they
want to,
they want to feel that Russia the cage,
they want to feel that rush at MMA gloves.
But there's,
there's no platform platform for,
to,
uh,
to do it besides mine.
So yeah,
it's um,
it's,
it's an interesting sort of a transition.
It's like the gladiator days where you're fighting in the coliseum.
Don't they do that in?
They do like
one what they wrap the hands.
They all do like big crazy hand wraps.
Yes.
They,
they,
they've just had of that in the last few years.
Also,
typhoid is called,
uh,
the same deal with the hand reps as well.
And the,
but a sinner rings still say you said a ring and they have a big giant hand
wraps.
They're not totally,
yeah,
I've heard rumors that there,
there may or may not be an MMA glove,
similar sort of stall underneath or if it's a softer cotton or it's not like
pure big.
Yeah,
it's big.
Those are big hand wraps.
It's not like as simple as like the regular wrap that you would wear when you're
boxing.
Yeah.
And it's on the calendar go out.
No,
it's not an aesthetic.
Do you think how the cage is a big selling element?
Um,
I know when I walk into arena and I see a ring,
it's like,
Yay,
the flight's tonight.
You beauty.
I'm excited.
I walk into arena and I see a cage and it's like,
oh she's,
someone's going to get fucked up tonight.
It's gonna be,
it's,
it's a different base.
You're walking.
Did I read it?
And it's a different,
it's a different animal.
It's funny to see that because that was always like a thing that people thought
was holding him and me back examine may was in a cage and people didn't like the
idea of cage fighting in quotes,
cage fighting it.
Now it's $1 billion business.
It's well,
UFC UFC is not MMA.
UFC,
you know there was an article that was recently out about the world series of
fighting,
which has some really good fighters in the world series of fighting.
You know there's some,
there's some super high level guys in in the world series of fighting.
You watch some real good fights and they're not making any money.
They're losing money.
They're on NBC sports,
you know,
and I don't know how much NBC sports pays them,
but it was some article on the underground about them losing money and being in
dire,
dire financial straits.
And for me as a fan,
I hate hearing that because I want guys to have options because when guys get
cut from the UFC,
a lot of times they'll go to world tour as a fighting one of these other
organizations like Jake shields or John Fitch and you know,
they're build up when a few fights over there and maybe they can come back to
the UFC.
And I like hearing that.
I want,
I want to see that.
That's what happened to our Lawsky Anthony Johnson,
Anthony Johnson,
he fought Arlovski in the world series of fighting.
Yes.
I like that.
I that has to be available and it can't be available if these guys aren't making
any money.
It's the same in Australia that the eye,
I love UFC.
I love it.
I'm there every single weekend.
I'm balling a little paper views.
I'm watching all the replays.
I love your commentary.
Uh,
I love every single thing about it.
And then I go to a local MMA show and I'm bored shitless.
Uh,
they got two guys that are in it.
It's in Australia too,
cause we didn't wrestle.
Said say within 10 seconds,
they're both on the ground and they don't have the skillset to stand back up.
And they sort of get stuck for five minutes.
But wait,
when you watch UFC there,
it's such a high level that it's,
it's like two worms.
The next minute they're up again.
They're down the Jujitsu.
So crazy.
The striking.
So amazing.
You've got the Surooney's and it's,
it's,
it's such a,
and then what I want to do with the CMT two on for Dana white saying in
interviews if any competition promotion was that it had any
brains,
they'd steal everything that I'm doing in the UFC and try and replicate that for
their own promotion because what we're doing is a winning formula.
So that's what I want to try and do with my show.
I'm trying to bring in the nationals in,
I'm trying to decorate the every single aspect as much as I can.
Similar but in the striking world.
So do you think that that's what you'll be your primary focus when you retire
and promoting and promoting like cage Moitai I,
yeah,
my life is fighting whether I'm doing an o promoting it or teaching it or
seminars or I have no other interest outside of fighting.
That ad is all I do.
And then that's my,
my wife's life as well between us.
Um,
yeah,
that's the eighth.
I don't know.
I didn't even know that there is a world outside of fighting.
When you watch MMA and so you watch like UFC a high level UFC,
what,
what is the one thing that you think that,
uh,
when you see a little striking,
is there anything that bugs you is you think that things that you watch it,
you see people doing wrong or things you would like to see them improve upon?
I enjoy,
I enjoy worries.
I enjoy people that are willing to put it all on the line.
Uh,
even,
uh,
gentlemen such as Diego Sanchez,
like he's striking to me isn't elite,
but at the same time he,
he,
he drops his hands,
he causes his opponent on,
he screams and he runs in.
For me.
That's excitement.
It doesn't,
it doesn't have to be technical or textbook,
but to have that,
uh,
that adrenaline dump of sitting there and watching him for a whole round just
going crazy to me,
that's,
that's amazing.
He's one of my all time favorites for sure.
Because of that.
And then John Jones,
again,
like you're saying,
different elements of his elbow strikes a goof.
Listen for another example,
uh,
there,
everyone has their Anthony Johnson,
he's boxing.
You wouldn't say his textbook boxing,
but at the same time if he hit you year out.
So I love that.
I love it.
That's why I love it because I'm on the edge of my seat every single,
if that's what UFC so good too.
You don't have to wait until the main event to watch the fight.
She can sit there from the prelims to the last fight and enjoy every single
fight because you know that every single fight is going to be completely
different.
To the last question about that,
but as a world class striker,
when you watch guys in the UFC,
do you see holes in their,
their style or do,
when you watch MMA,
it doesn't even have to be UFC,
like just any MMA.
Do you see,
like,
what do you think about the level when you come from a world championship Muay
Thai fighters perspective,
what do you think about the level of kickboxing and MMA?
Uh,
if it,
if it was pure kickboxing rules.
It.
Yeah,
it's,
it's different kettle of fish,
but,
um,
it's,
it's entertaining.
I watch it for then.
Yeah.
I can't,
I can't say it's good or bad because what they're do works.
And also you have to consider the fact that they're avoiding take downs and
things.
There's so many different elements for me,
for me to say,
this is good,
this is bad.
Um,
I would be disrespecting the sports,
so I'd rather I,
it's in the day.
Uh,
it's entertainment and that's why I invested my money every single weekend.
Cause I love it.
I think it's amazing.
And I'm a,
I'm a Moitai guy.
I love UFC.
So yeah,
I just wish I was
a young teenager.
They're just letting you know.
I know.
I know which path.
I definitely go.
You'd go down the MMA path.
I see.
Yeah.
I wasn't so big.
I want to be the Anthony Pettis on the Wheaties box.
I'd love to,
I'd love to be the George St Ph
in living in a penthouse and being in the UN unlost commercials in the run the
reality.
And then there's,
yeah,
it's be,
do you plan on training MMA fighters?
Do you mean,
I know you work with George quite a bit.
Uh,
I've worked with him once for the two weeks.
That was pretty cool.
Um,
I worked with a couple of gentlemen in Australia that are coming up,
so,
but if the opportunity arose and someone would like to to,
yeah,
shoot me an email,
I'm happy to know all those training sessions that you did with George over the
two weeks.
Which fight was that for Hendrix?
Hendrix.
He's very last one.
And w what did you guys basically work on?
Was Hendrick was a southpaw.
So we're working on,
uh,
keeping everything basic and then lots of right hand left hooks,
lots of insight.
Like he's with the right leg for the,
the tech yet that lead Southport leg,
uh,
moving away from the power left hand because he's a monster.
Uh,
and then every time we'd spa I replicate a Johnny spiring style.
So lots of,
I'd throw lots of overhand lefts and just being that,
that craziness exploding in.
Um,
and then Georgia was,
uh,
John Denver here,
um,
after a week of having George on the pads,
he was blown away about how much power I,
I,
I was starting to get out of George's,
um,
punches and kicks and then freestyling and the pads that he never number four.
And um,
yeah,
it was,
we had such a good time.
Uh,
but then I came to la,
I came too early in the camp.
There was still 14 weeks between our training session and the fight.
So by the time I went back to Australia,
uh,
he,
he sort of went back to the old training regime.
And then what was the difference between your training?
When I had the pleasure of working out with you and one of the things that I
found was really interesting is that even when you throw a jab,
you're throwing a jab almost like a right hand.
He's throwing a jab,
like you're pulling back with your right hand and fucking thrusting with your
left hand.
Yes.
Was that like the style that I had,
George George,
when George was double jabbing before it was a long Jab,
Short Jab was I had him cocking that shoulder for both jabs.
So both of them were,
were um,
and I'll make them big cracking was Bam Bam.
Yeah.
That you were trying to get him to be more aggressive with his power or is that
what you were concentrating on joining to execute?
Um,
yeah,
well a lot more power shots and just keeping it simple.
So,
uh,
keeping it down to four or five different techniques against a southpaw,
because against the South Pole,
you,
you can't do the crazy tricks.
You've got to keep it basic.
But I'm smart so you don't want to run into that left power hand either.
And then I believe,
uh,
he fought the wrong fight against Johnny.
He was moving into the hand instead of away from the hand and then he took a lot
of damage.
Uh,
and I believe we talked about this last time as well.
I,
I believe George marginally just won that fight,
just,
um,
but I,
I think if I had stayed there for a little bit longer or closer to the fight,
I,
I could have gotten away with them.
Less damage.
Um,
yeah.
Do you think the punishment,
sorry,
do you think that he,
maybe he had one foot out the door because he was kind of saying after that fire
through is really,
you know,
it's,
it's probably wants to take some time on any one of retiring,
but he wanted to take some time away and that this was just a,
you know,
it was too much for him.
Do you think that coming into that fight,
maybe he had that in his head?
Possibly.
It's always a bad spot for a fighter to be at.
Right?
I have one foot out the door.
Yeah.
I was saying to my friend Kevin,
uh,
I,
it was the highlight of my,
uh,
training as a person who was training George first two weeks and the first three
days that I was with him,
it was so mind blowing that how famous he was.
People coming up morning taken further is we,
we're eating.
And then after the third day,
fourth day fee,
then you realize this thing,
this,
the machine doesn't turn off.
And then,
um,
he can't go to the chemist to buy shampoo.
He can't chemist,
let's call a pharmacy,
call the cameras.
Do you go,
where the fuck are you getting your champion?
He might go,
he might go into the toilets to pass stool and you've got people waiting at the
side of the cubicle to wait to get a photo with him.
So He's,
and then we've got to,
every time we went somewhere,
it always have to be through the VIP entrance.
He couldn't walk through the front door,
uh,
especially Montreal.
Right?
So one time we went to a nightclub and then we've got in through the VIP and
then we'll,
we'll walk into our,
uh,
our table.
And then we're about maybe 15 feet from their table and someone says,
Jews Birger as p and would,
where the word of a lie.
Um,
the whole dance force stopped dancing.
Everyone's looked at us turn and the whole club's walk towards that table.
And,
um,
without losing a beat,
we've turned straight back around and walked straight back out.
And that club,
because,
uh,
it was like a tsunami of fans that had just come into real sit down.
He said,
well,
we'll come back here in a couple of years later when that,
when they're distracted.
Um,
I can't come in right now because of this.
Every day is this doesn't,
yeah,
I,
this is,
this is normal.
And he's,
what he has is a good friends that are his body bodyguards that stand around in
the whole time because,
uh,
people said,
can I get a photo?
And the body guys will step in and say,
oh,
no,
no.
Flashy.
As soon as the flash goes off,
then the whole club's going to come.
And then Georgia say yes,
and then the body goes,
oh,
sorry.
Ah,
but George say,
yes,
look me.
You don't understand.
If the camera goes in,
we got a problem and everybody's gonna want to photo in any,
even at a red light.
We're driving in the car.
Me and George got the radio,
big jar.
We stopped,
we stopped at a red light.
And the way he was GSP,
GSP and four t's credit champion,
easy always Luke's wave smalls and then certainly just juice for just a fraction
just so he's out of eyesight of of the fans.
But it's um,
but that's every,
every single he'd rather from your car park even he'd catch a taxi from the
front gate to the back gate because it from walking a hundred feet would be a
half an hour,
um,
with photos and handshakes and high fives and,
and people are rude.
People are crazy.
People would just come up and they stick their phone in his face like this and
then you know what it's like you're a superstar and you'd have this every single
day as well.
Surely you don't have any my sticking their phone directly in my face too often,
but it's happened a few times.
Yeah.
I think with George is a totally different thing because he's a national hero as
well.
I mean he won sportsman of the year award in Canada where hockey is like their
national sport.
Yes.
And he went over hockey players.
I mean,
he was on the fucking,
he was in these Gatorade commercials.
I mean,
he had transcended the sport to the,
to the fact,
the point where he was a international superstar and he's from Canada and
they're so proud of that in Canada.
Canada's such a proud country.
Yes.
But a guy like George is probably a hundred times more famous than me.
We'll wait till we went to New York for the,
for one week,
the train with them,
John Dana here.
And I'm at the Gracies as academy.
And even in New York it was,
it was no different.
Montreal and New York was just as insane as each other that it was just,
well,
I would think metro,
I'll be probably a little bit more crazy.
But yeah,
at that level,
I mean,
George,
when he was a champion,
especially,
I wonder if he could get around now a little bit better.
Yeah,
I hope so.
I mean,
people just ask them questions.
When are you coming back,
George?
Who's going to find it as a silver George?
Um,
yeah.
And then even the websites,
you notice all the,
uh,
I read the MMA websites,
said Bree single day,
and then there's always at least once a week there's something about George is
doing this or he might come back or this is happening.
And so he's still,
he's still relevant.
He's still hasn't disappeared yet.
There's still that.
They still need him in that circle.
We still training Norco was a in,
um,
Tristar recently and he had done some training with George and I think,
you know,
George still has a little bit of the Itch,
but yeah,
I'd love for him to come back.
I think he's,
uh,
he's,
he is UFC and he's such a great ambassador as well.
He's not just the gentleman,
not just a great fighter,
but he represents everything good.
That's about combat sports.
I agree.
Everything good about martial arts.
And he started as a martial artist.
I mean,
that's really what he is.
Yes.
And that's why he would always go to the,
and to the octagon with his key on.
And you know,
the whole deal.
He's a,
he's a real unique guy and no better ambassador.
Like in,
in his time to carry the flag.
Yes.
And then,
uh,
to,
um,
even,
uh,
a lot of people change after the ones that reached out to superstardom,
whereas George has always stayed grounded and then people would come up and
people had some majority of great and then some people with the Thomas Baling,
Hey,
every time I get a photo of a celebrity I get carried say,
pick me up.
And he's like,
oh,
okay.
They took her or uh,
just,
just people are so fucking weird.
Especially every time I get a photo of a celebrity,
I fart on them.
Yeah,
come on over here.
I'm gonna on your own.
They might have had a few drinks and there's no politeness.
Hey,
I want a photo.
Give me a photo.
Well they just grabbed him.
What that twice in a highlight where they grab me around the neck,
give me a photo and just people of this news and he doesn't change though.
He's like,
he doesn't like it,
but at the same time he does it well.
He's a,
he's a good man.
Yeah,
man.
He's a very open minded to have watched him train with people.
I think I've seen you in a few confrontations on Youtube where people are a bit
aggressive when it comes.
The comes to asking for your stuff and you give half to give them a slight,
hey,
just not,
I don't know necessarily.
I don't think there's any youtube videos of people like asking for photos or
anything like that.
It might be that,
I don't know,
but yeah,
people get drunk.
Yeah.
Alcohol's the worst drug in the world.
It's the worst drug in the world for people to make mistakes under pressure too
because they see a guy like George and the like hold shoots,
chores,
superior orange cured to him.
You know like whatever.
The stupid chocolate dao used to get.
God's trying to pick fights with them with fucking chocolate.
Chocolate.
Dow has all murderers.
I like you look in his eyes,
there's killer in there and do it to get drunk and pick fights with them.
People are so stupid.
[inaudible] Donald owned.
He was telling me some guy putting on the podcast,
it sounds like some guy punched him in the face and the whole foods parking lot.
Hey.
And he's like,
what the fuck man?
It's like Jesus Christ.
You just run into the wrong people,
man and booze and whatever fuck out they're doing with their head.
Yeah.
It's a crap shoot out there.
And you meet the general public.
Um,
yes.
So,
uh,
about youtube.
Holy Shit Man.
You had that little spa.
People are fucking crazy.
Why do people get um,
they stay anonymous yet they have such an opinion that they have to me and you,
we,
we had an understanding.
You had a sore back.
He didn't want a spa,
but you were,
you said,
oh look,
fuck it,
let's do it.
And then,
uh,
we had the best three minutes.
We laughed,
we had fun.
It was no big deal.
I said,
do you mind if I upload it?
You said,
yeah,
go for it.
Yeah.
Everyone thinks it's so serious.
And I also think where somehow upset at each other or something.
It was just,
to me it was fun.
It was fun.
It was cool.
It was a highlight of a,
we should have probably recorded the whole thing.
The,
there was a highlight of like an whatever,
an hour and a half of us training together.
I was,
I was really impressed with the lot of the variations of techniques you do.
Like the way you throw the knee.
Especially,
I never saw anybody throw a knee with like it completely sideways the way you
did it and the combinations in which you did it.
So I think in MMA or an in any martial art,
it's always cool when you get a chance to work with people and learn a bunch of
different shit and at the end of it like throwing some light kicks and and you
know,
and punches and stuff and moving around with each other.
To me it was just fun.
Yeah.
The suspected a bulging disc.
Well it's definitely something with it,
but it's better now that take it like,
like we were competing like,
like a UFC title.
It was a place by or in your garage for shits and giggles.
You can't read that though,
man.
You can't.
You're reading the comments.
You can't read those.
That's like open yourself up to the retards of the world.
Like,
Hey retards.
How do you,
what do you,
how do you feel I should govern my life?
What should I do differently?
Well,
good news or
some shit.
You just can't,
you can't listen to that.
I remember I sent you a private message about two weeks,
let us gun do.
How do you,
how do you put up with it?
And you said,
you said just read it.
Your hook or folk don't go to good to be a world trip.
But if it was balled me bro and open them up and then,
yeah,
then directing your technique.
It was hilarious.
Was just please shut the fuck up.
There was a segment of you showing me a particular combination and someone was
saying that you were showing it wrong.
Oh yeah.
I was reading that and I was like,
what am I reading this?
What am I,
what am I doing?
I'm,
I'm not even taking my own advice.
And meanwhile if you,
if you found that guy probably weighs six pounds,
he's in his mom's basement,
shit in his own pants.
Like who knows who you're listening when you read a sentence on the Internet and
it starts with a letter and it ends with a period,
it looks like a normal person wrote it and you just read it.
Like if you wrote a sentence or if he wrote a sentence or some crazy dude who
has no fucking grasp of reality at all,
it still looks the same because it's a sentence and you don't know.
Like when you read someone's opinion,
you don't know what the,
what's that guy like?
Like that's the thing about opinions.
If you,
there's always guys and you know them,
everybody knows him.
There's always guys in the gym that will see someone and they probably don't
know what the fuck they're doing,
but they'll see someone hitting the bag or they see someone doing the technique
and they'll come over and correct them.
Right?
There's always those fucking morons,
you know,
there's a million of those fucking morons,
right?
Well,
when you meet that guy and you know he's an idiot and you know that guy from the
gym,
you can just go,
oh,
Mike is the guy who gave you advice.
Mike's half retarded.
He got shot in the head when he was two.
You know what?
This is a difference.
Treat that and like seeing the guy's written words.
It's the beautiful thing about the Internet is that anybody can say anything.
They can just that you,
you,
you have a full open,
free forum for expressing yourself.
But the reality is if you have a million people,
okay,
at least 1% of those people are going to be out of their fucking minds.
At least 1% so if you've got a hundred people,
that's one person.
But if you've got a million people or 100 million people,
look at the United States,
300 million people,
how many of those people are out of their fucking mind?
It's at least 3 million.
At least 3 million douchebag.
They're leaving comments on Youtube and they get in John Wayne part and talk
about them.
I was right.
It was right.
He was,
say it all you want,
you'll fucking techniques dog shit.
I don't know how you got to be a world champion Brown.
Not,
not on my watch.
I'll tell you what,
it's switch gonna get man.
It's the world,
the world we live in.
It's a beautiful world though.
It's beautiful and it's chaos and it's,
it's fun.
But you got to,
I think we're all learning how to navigate this world and the world of comments
on like,
I have friends that won't go on the underground anymore.
You know,
fighters,
they just won't go.
The Guy,
I can't,
it hurts my feelings.
They go,
I'll read it,
but which people are saying about me and it hurts me,
but it only hurts you if you don't know that.
If you,
if you knew that guy wouldn't hurt you,
you know,
if you were around him when he was saying that,
you'd be like,
Oh,
you're a fucking idiot.
You're an idiot with a typewriter.
You get it.
The type keys.
Oh,
okay.
I get it.
But you don't get it.
When you see this a sentence,
a sentence.
It looks like a normal person wrote that Diego Sanchez written wrote on Twitter
and saying,
you bag me up.
But I bet if we met in person,
you'd be the first one to me for my gruff.
Oh,
it's true.
They would just say that to him.
Yeah.
They talk all kinds of shit with them.
How can you talk shit about Diego Sanchez?
Yeah.
That guy has given more people the most crazy holy shit.
Entertainment.
Diego's had more fucking wild,
chaotic filled rounds and wild moments in MMA fucker wins.
Fights in the third round when he's losing the first two rounds,
he's got his face hanging off and he doesn't give off fuck and he still comes
out swinging.
You have to be a real piece of shit to talk bad about that guy.
A real piece of shit.
Melinda is that third round?
It's still one of my favorite room.
How he dropped him in an uppercut and the fucking third round I have to lose in
those first two rounds drops him,
almost has 'em out.
Same thing with Jake Ellenberger.
He's back to take his bag.
Man Diego's a warrior that guys my respect forever.
He's so crazy.
Martin Kampmann fight.
Same thing.
First two rounds.
Losing his fucking face is falling off in the third round.
He's chasing Martin Kampmann down.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
you got to good ears.
Pick worries is,
I mean,
it's just,
there's a bunch of disrespectful shitheads out there.
And just do you think,
do you think it's because of the,
um,
with my toy,
for instance,
we have a culture that's very Buddhism and is very sweaty cop and everything.
The whole business.
It isn't that it's pain that that means what you're saying.
Ah,
yeah,
it's an hour and put it in.
But most of these people full time to time,
the class,
the whole prayer,
it's,
it's a way of showing that I'm anomaly.
That's the original,
instead of shaking hands or toys and then the males aren't touching the females
either.
It's more of a,
it's a,
it's a real humility in a real honest appreciation of each other.
And they had this century old culture,
whereas the MMA is so tapping out written,
uh,
bad wise,
just the,
the fans are,
it's a different sort of culture.
Do you believe it's Sorta,
well that bro Dude,
bullshit was frowned upon and talk window.
I mean,
I grew up in talk window and which is very,
I always spoke to my instructor.
I called him Sir or mister,
Mr. Kim or sir,
he said what?
He said something to me,
there was no question.
It was always yes sir.
And it was always,
there was this bowing respect type admiration that you had for your instructor
and for fellow competitors.
And that was,
that's a big part of what martial arts is.
This is respect for each other.
And on the other hand,
I like the shit talking.
I like,
like with Conor McGregor does,
I like the just bleed guy in the audience.
It's fun too,
but I think you lose something where there's a,
there's a beautiful respect to [inaudible].
And there's another thing about ties.
The audiences are respectful.
When you go to those events,
like you very rarely hear stupid shipping yelled at,
even though people were drinking.
There's a,
there's applause for both the winner and the loser is a tremendous amount of
respect that's involved in it because,
because it's not that popular because it's not mainstream.
Those people in the audience have a deep appreciation for the art of Moitai.
Yeah.
They hide.
They are there for,
because they want to see it.
It's not like it's on TV and then just watching it for the sake of watching that
they,
because they want to be there now.
That's the only reason.
It's not a scene.
It's like they're there to see Moy Tai.
Yeah.
And then,
um,
yeah,
they call the MMA culture.
Just say,
well,
there's a lot of fucking posing and fake and assholes and my friends,
I'll get my friends tickets,
you know,
and they'll go to the fights and they'll sit beside some guys like,
well,
does the fucking punk fucking kick people just yell out advice and they get
drunk and they're stupid.
They're posing because they're insecure.
So they're drunk at these events and they're trying to pretend that they know
more than the fighter.
No.
Yes.
Overwhelming.
Yeah.
I'm hoping that the human race survives this era.
I mean,
I'm really hoping that we just,
this Internet era enlightens us to our douchey ways and we just,
we just slowly but surely rise from the ashes of what we've created.
But I don't know when I read comments,
I get confused.
Who
listen to my brother.
We just did three hours.
We're out of time.
Sorry.
Nine o'clock.
This is the John Wayne Parks parents night.
Thank you again anytime,
man.
Open invitation please.
My pleasure.
Any time.
And next time we town was train small.
Let's do it again,
but still a lot of fun.
When are you going to be around again?
You have any plans?
I'm talking to Hans Hands.
I'm talking to Scott Kin.
Uh,
hopefully I'll be back as soon as I fuck you.
They have to have you back,
man.
It happened,
and next time you come back,
we'll uh,
make sure,
probably try to get you in before too so people can tune in and know that the
fight is coming.
John Wayne,
parlays gentlemen,
follow him on Twitter.
John Wayne,
par on Twitter cage cage boy,
tie dot until December the fifth on the funding side.
Cyrus us not whoever that other guy is that he invented.
Cyrus Washington,
black dynamite should be a lot of fun.
And can people watch that online or anything like,
yes.
I'm going to have,
uh,
it'll,
it'll fight live TV.
They'll come fight live tv.com.
I will tweet it.
I'll let you guys know about it.
December 5th.
Thank you my brother.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you folks.
We'll be back tomorrow until then.
Be Nice to each other.
Bye Bye.